this is jocko podcast number 320 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening
so there's a
a common set of
metaphors that get thrown around a
decent amount
something along the lines of
we as people we're authors of our own
book
and we're the star of our own
movie
you heard these things before i have
yeah
and they
when you hear them when i just said them
and even the way i said them they seem
kind of trite and they seem
cliched and i guess they are but
like many cliches they are
true in many ways
and there's
an analogy in those statements with the
idea of
extreme ownership
take take ownership of your life that's
this similar to hey you write your own
book
you get to create the plot is the is the
underlying theme which means that you
have control and obviously
i like that idea
i like that that attitude
and i agree with the idea of creating
your own plot and writing your own book
that you're in
but it
doesn't quite correlate 100
because
here's the thing
if you are truly writing your own script
then you actually have control over
everything
that's happening
you have 100 control over everything
that you're writing you're writing it
but in life in real life
there are things that are beyond your
control in war the enemy gets a vote
in
life life gets a vote
life gets a vote
bad things are going to happen things
that you don't expect
disease
accidents misfortunes mishaps
catastrophes
and it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter who you are or what
situation you are in these things are
going to impact your life at some point
no one gets out of life without these
things happening
no one truly gets to write their own
script
so the question is what do you do with
these things when they hit you
how do you face these challenges
how do you
actually take ownership of your life
it is not an easy thing to do
but we are lucky enough today
to have someone here that
has taken ownership of his life
and has dedicated his life to service
he served in the seal teams
once he got out of the seal teams
created an incredibly successful
business
he serves his family serves his wife and
his two daughters he serves his faith
and now he is looking to serve his
country again
as a political leader
his name is eli crane
and he is here tonight to share his
experiences
and pass on some of those lessons
learned that he got along the way
eli crane
thanks for coming down man thanks for
having me jaco appreciate it long drive
out from arizona i know about five and a
half hours but it was a good one though
uh let's jump into this so speaking of
arizona let's start at the beginning
let's start about your past
and where you came from
yeah i actually um was born in tucson
arizona
my dad was going to pharmacy school out
there
both my parents are from iowa and they
moved out here
go to a good pharmacy school and uh
there were a lot of pharmacy jobs in the
west so my dad went through pharmacy
school then moved us down to yuma
arizona of all places yeah and so was
there a job or something down there
there was and that's why that's why he
did it
and it's cool because uh i remember a
lot of my a lot of my buddies in the
platoon were always complaining about
you know iraq and the heat and i was
like this is like where i'm from man you
know
except arabic street signs and maybe an
extra dust storm here there this is like
kind of like yuma without the good
mexican food but
but yeah so grew up in uh grew up in
yuma and uh
you know just uh
you know loved playing sports was a
football player i played a little bit of
basketball and stuff like that wanted to
be a pro football player but then i
realized you know i ran into reality
and realized that i didn't have didn't
have the skills and uh started looking
at other options was your so your dad
was actually completed pharmacy school
when he was a pharmacist yes and what
about your mom was she doing the same
thing or did she start raising the kids
yeah she was uh she was raising the kids
and she was also she also did some
part-time work at our church as a
secretary so
so you were spending time in church than
when you were younger yeah i did
how was uh how was the attention span in
school and whatnot it was a good student
no i was a horrible student it was funny
i remember you know
thank god you know jocko you talk about
dynamic leadership sometimes they're
like hey what works for this individual
doesn't work for that individual but um
it was interesting because i remember my
mom thank god she you know tried to be
dynamic in parenting me and my brothers
because my older brother my older
brother and younger brother were good
students
but me on the other hand not so much
were you the you're the middle right i
was the middle and they were i remember
my mom coming home from a parent-teacher
conference and she's like you know
eli is in the classroom
but he's not really here
and like i was always daydreaming i was
out at recess chasing butterflies
whatever i was doing but yeah i didn't
and it was interesting because as i as i
went down that pipeline
you know um i started to think you know
people would tell me like especially my
brothers you know you always rise your
brothers give each other a hard time and
my brothers you know i i probably dished
out more than i
than i received but
um
you know they would tell me that i was
stupid because my grades were awful and
so you hear it you hear something enough
time you're stupid you're stupid you're
stupid you start to internalize it and
you know you can easily make that a part
of your identity so
um i did and you know i started to think
i was stupid and then as i got as i got
further along in life and i started you
know finding what i was passionate about
i realized that i wasn't stupid
i just you know needed to have that
energy and my attention funneled in the
right direction towards something that i
really cared about
so you played
football did you say football and what
you know i played football a little bit
of basketball but
most of my focus was football and you
played all through high school yeah how
good were you
you know i was decent um
but i wasn't i wasn't good enough to
move on to college i played you know i
played quarterback i loved you know
playing quarterback i loved the team
dynamics of football but uh it was
interesting
and you know i gotta take extreme
ownership of this but
my coach we had like three slow white
quarterbacks and in high school our
coaches decided to switch us to an
option you know running football team so
it was kind of like
you know none of us were even really in
a system that you know
really uh
highlighted our skills our preferred
skill sets or what we were even good at
but
um and there was there was one guy
that ended up starting over me and uh
unfortunately he was juicing at the time
and i was like a scrawny like hundreds
you know it wasn't unfortunate for him
apparently
he was like i was six one like 170
pounds just really really scrawny hadn't
put on any weight yet and uh he had he
could throw about 15 yards further than
me and he he got he he started so
it is what it is didn't get you know
didn't
it didn't get the opportunity to really
start once i got deeper i started all
the way up to like my junior year and
then you know i got benched and
uh the bottom line is you know i wasn't
good enough to make it happen and i'm
looking back on it hindsight being what
it is i'm kind of glad because i'm
pretty pretty thrilled about the route
that i ended up going down
and then you
you you stayed in yuma is that where you
went to high school yeah that's where i
went to high school cibola high school
and your parents
were
just continuing to work and yeah get you
ready for
life yep pretty much just raising me and
my two brothers and
um
yeah i mean
you know i feel pretty fortunate to grow
up in the home that i did you know my
parents loved us they provided for us
etc and
um
you know i realize a lot of a lot of
folks don't get that so pretty grateful
for that
and then were you planning to go to
college
was that part of your plan uh yeah i i
was planning to go to college but i was
hoping that i could go there and play
football like that was my focus that was
my goal and uh
and then i also wanted to be in the
military at some point and so the advice
that i was getting was hey eli if you're
gonna go to college you know uh or if
you're gonna go into the military go
through go through school get your
degree become an officer you know and
you'll get a lead man the pay is better
etc and
you know that wasn't the path i ended up
taking but
did you did you get better grades as you
got older or did you
did your brothers scar you to the point
where you were just not doing any
schoolwork at all no my
so when i got out of uh when i got out
of high school i started working some
like odd jobs like construction you know
at one point i was like a score keeper
down at parks and rec you know for like
softball games
stuff like that i was working at a
restaurant as like a busboy you know
definitely not on the on the path to
this is when you got out of high school
yeah when i got out of high school did
you didn't go right into college i
didn't okay and then uh
and then i was kind of i was kind of
lost and it was right after my parents
divorce and my parents divorce was
pretty tough and so it kind of rocked my
world i was definitely you know a little
bit rattled so i was trying to figure
how old were you and your parents got
divorced i was 17.
so um you know thankfully like i said i
got my parents together for most of my
you know upbringing but it was it was a
pretty brutal divorce and so it just
really rocked my world and
um i was you know took some time trying
to figure out who the hell i was what i
was going to do
and
and then i started i i started going
back to a community college called
arizona western
and i started studying criminology and
that's when i started getting good
grades because i i loved it
i loved it and you know i was i wasn't
getting straight a's but i think i had
like a three three five average or
something like that and uh
you know i enjoyed it
and how long did that last for so i did
that for about two years
i i think i was one credit away like i'm
elective away from getting my uh my
associate's degree and then i applied to
go to the university of arizona
unfortunately when i got to the
university of arizona they didn't have
like a criminology degree they had like
a
some criminal justice degree but i'd
have to go to eller business school and
i didn't get into that one
you had to have really good grades to
get into it
and uh and so i ended up being like okay
i still want to finish my degree still
want to have the opportunity to become
an officer if possible
and so i was like okay
be being the typical you know i was like
okay what's
what path can i go that allows allows me
to do that and so i
looked at sociology the study of society
and culture and i started uh
you know uh working on my major and that
i switched my major at that point
because because they didn't have the
criminology major were you thinking
about the seal teams or were you just
thinking about the military in general
did you know yeah so at that point i
knew i wanted to be a seal
um
even when i was back in yuma before i
came to tucson
um i was never a big party or anything
like that and i remember
when i was even when i was doing the odd
jobs one of my favorite things to do at
night was to go to barnes and noble and
just like
you know really go through
the military history section that they
have there and i would just read books
on special forces pjs rangers
delta and i was just fascinated by the
special forces community and i remember
my dad gave me a piece of advice in high
school he said eli
the trick to being happy in your career
is basically to pick something you would
do for free don't don't pick a career
because of money it won't make you happy
and uh and he told me if i could if i
could go back and do it again i wouldn't
be a pharmacist he said i could have
gone and you know you know been a forest
ranger or something like that i would i
would do that and so i took that advice
on board and i was like oh man i was
reading the books and i was like
jumping out of airplanes blowing stuff
up you know shooting you know being with
you know being in a team environment
dude i'd do that for free for sure and
so i started setting my mind on
special forces
is there something that particularly
narrowed it down to the seal teams yeah
because all the literature that i was
almost almost all of it
said that it was the toughest training
in the department of defense
and
i don't know there was something about
that that just appealed to me like i
wanted to test myself and see if i could
uh
if i had what it took to to make it
through the toughest training in the
world and then i i loved the water or i
thought i did you know
that that that notion gets tested yeah
that notion gets tested picked up how
old were you when you were figuring all
that out was that when you were already
at the university of arizona
yeah um so it was even when i was you
know definitely thinking about it even
when i was at arizona western i was also
thinking about would it be cool to be a
fed because i was studying criminology
you know federal law enforcement or
something like that
and then uh as soon as i got to u of a
um
you know i started studying sociology
which i really i was back in that i
really don't like this that much
um and i really i could even see kind of
the indoctrination within academia at
that point and i was like i'm really not
on board with a lot of this
extracurricular stuff that they're
putting out here and kind of the the
bent that a lot of academia has
um and so
i started i found a program in rotc i
started i realized okay there is an rotc
program here there's a lot of military
folks maybe i should go get
hooked into that and so i did and i
found that they had a ranger challenge
program at u of a
and so i was like oh cool man i want to
see if i can join and get into that
maybe i could learn a little bit and you
know network and just figure out start
start working towards getting in the
right type of shape
and so i i started doing the ranger
challenge program and you know we'd have
to you know wake up do early morning pts
and you know just get some exposure to
that culture into leaders within that
culture and so i started doing that
and that was helpful so what year is
this so that would have been probably
2 000.
so were you in college when september
11th came i was i was um i was just
starting my senior year at the u of a
and i was doing that ranger challenge
program
you know my grades were decent i was a
lifeguard at the u of a rec center and
um
and 9 11 happened i just finished a
ranger challenge workout early in the
morning
got in my car turned on the radio and i
was driving back to where i lived and it
was all over the radio and i was like
damn i was actually in a agricultural
fraternity called alpha gamma rho at the
time so i drove home and i was like i
woke up all the guys who were still
asleep and i was like dude you guys got
to get out here and watch this and so we
all we all got up watched it and
everybody was just obviously stunned and
surprised and pissed off at the same
time
and so
i remember um wanting to join you know
obviously i had i wanted to join the
military and i remember
you know taking a couple days to think
about it but i'm just like i gotta go
you know and i remember calling my my
mom and my dad and telling them hey look
i've decided i'm gonna go join the
military i'm gonna drop out of school
and join the military because i just
really felt like hey there's never gonna
be a time like this you know where the
nation needs the next crop to step up
and serve and so um
i actually dropped out that week went
and you know dropped out all my classes
and then went down started talking to
the recruiter and playing those games
with the recruiter and then within
probably i think seven or eight days
i was we were driving up to phoenix so
that i could get on a plane and fly to
great lakes and it was pretty quick dude
that's really quick yep and was it like
a single contract was it what was it a
seal contract yeah was it called dive
fare
that's what i did i don't think that's
what i did back in 1820
no it was it wasn't called that i can't
remember i can't remember what it was
called but they did guarantee me the
opportunity to do a screen test and try
out yeah which is if you think about
that is the
shallowest guarantee you could ever get
to sign your life away right hey here
you sign this piece of paper for six
years in the navy
and you will be guaranteed
a chance to take a street screening test
that might get you picked up for buds
right that's a slim offering i know it
and you rogered up i did i did and uh
you know i'm
i wouldn't looking back on it now i
don't think i would change it
even though i i never have still to this
day never finished my degree you know
for a couple different reasons and uh
but i think
this i think it was the right thing to
do and i'm glad that you know there were
a lot there were thousands of americans
that did the exact same thing yeah tim
kennedy was saying that same thing he
went down the recruiter like september
12th or whatever yep and he said the
line was around the building and
everything
so you showed up to boot camp yep
in chicago yep
and was it was it a shock to the system
well big time
yeah i don't know who doesn't get a
shock when you show up to boot camp even
navy boot camp which is you know
relatively
mild i guess
compared to like let's say the marine
corps boot camp
but just the
immediate loss of all your personal
freedom right and personal space
it's kind of a it's kind of a little bit
of a shocker echo i understand
and what were you going to be
so i uh back then
i mean obviously your goal was to be a
seal but you had to take a rate right
yep what
gunners mate was a seal source rate at
the time i think there were only five of
them so i was like gunners yeah that
sounds awesome so
so i chose gunners mate and uh
thankfully i chose a cool one because i
was going to spend some time in that
rate
yeah did you take the screening test i
did you passed it
not the first time the second time um
yeah man this you know this is something
even before old are you at this point i
am 20
i'm 21 years old okay
so um
i didn't pass my first one i passed i
passed the second one like i was
running in like steel the you know back
when you had to run the screen testing
like steel-toed boots
yeah
and i had gotten some what i would
consider today probably some pretty bad
gouge from a team guy um that i talked
to because i didn't know any seals you
know but my recruiter
he was like hey man there's some seals
out at ypg yuma proving ground her at
jump school we can go talk to him if you
want i was like yes i'd love to go talk
to one so i remember going out he drove
me out there and i talked to one and uh
he was like
he's like look man
the only way you're gonna know is if you
if you have what it takes it's just to
show up and do it he's like can you pass
the screen test and i was like yeah i
think i can
and so
that is
that is the worst advice ever so that's
what i was rolling i'm like this guy's a
navy seal dude this is what he told me
so um
and then so i you know once i got to the
level where you know i could do like i
could pass the screen test i was like
okay i'm good to go let's do it and uh
then when i got like i was but even when
i ran the screen test on my own i was
never running it in steel-toed boots and
pants and i don't and like a fool
when i did when i did this stuff i
didn't i didn't do it together and
that's a big deal though a lot of people
don't we a lot of people don't yeah dude
i can do 42 push-ups yeah i can do i can
do six pull-ups i can i can do all these
things individually but you're not
running them together and when you start
running them together with with the time
requirements in between it'll gas you
pretty quick
so
the first time i ran it man i was dry
heaving coming across the finish line
and uh failed but i got a chance to go
back and do it again then the next time
like i came in with like maybe a second
left
and uh they're like all right sweet you
get your still contract and i'm like yes
and so
um graduated from boot camp went to
gunners mate a school right there in
great lakes
and at that point they let us work out
with some actual seals we got to do copt
i think three times a week so i started
doing that
and it was kind of funny i had i have
hairy legs and so
there was this instructor hat joe biden
apparently right
wow
i didn't realize you've seen that video
right
i mean is there a crazier like no
combination of
randomness that you could put into a
video besides that joe biden and hairy
legs and the kids and the blonde hair
and the
most
insane thing yeah so anyways all right
so you got hairy legs yeah and so one of
the instructors his name was instructor
hatter he wouldn't even let me speak
english he made me speak in wookie like
and i used to be real good at like doing
the truth but it was like
like he made me run around and like you
know go report to so and so over there i
would run up to him and he'd make me
report like that and
he they loved it but whatever
and uh yeah so did the copt thing
graduate graduated gunners made a school
and then uh
went immediately to buds and classed up
with buds class 242.
did you get what you expected at buds oh
yeah and more
and more and uh
you know it was it was really it was
really interesting because um
i actually made it through hell week on
my first on my first attempt and uh you
know
definitely not heroic more like hanging
on by the you know
hanging on what were you having trouble
with
well yeah yeah i was i was having
trouble with buds um so i when i was
born i was born with
some doctors say that i had asthma some
said i had exercise induced bronchitis
whichever diagnosis is correct at the
end of the day
my lungs only function at about 60 and
that you know of what they're supposed
to and that's after even like an
albuterol hit or treatment and so
you know you can imagine
you know if your lungs are only
functioning at 60
and you've trained to the bare minimum
um
you're going to have a tough time and so
i i was having a really tough time and
so
um i made it
in i i walk around at about 225 pounds i
had because my lungs don't function at
the level they're supposed to i had to
get down to
175 pounds just to pass the screen test
right it's like a car right
we can't put a bigger engine in this
thing
you know we can't do a lot to it how how
do we make it we start stripping weight
out of it throw the back seat you know
like get rid of weight because just
saying it is only going to go as fast as
it goes and so
started really you know getting really
thin really thin and that had that this
is while you were in buds
i had to get i had to get really thin
before even going to buds just because
you know was this while you were at gma
school yeah so while you're gma school
you're just dropping weight yep trying
to get trying to get be able to run
faster and you show up at buds
and you're hurting yeah and it wasn't
honestly it wasn't just that it wasn't
just that like i was immature as well
um you know i had uh
that's one thing that like i when i talk
to people about seal training and buds
and the fact that they're trying to form
you into a team guy
um
when i first showed up i was immature
and i was like i was looking out for
number one i was looking out for me i
was like man and it wasn't like i was a
like i was a jerk but if if i'm
struggling if i'm on the struggle bus
over here and i haven't grown up and
matured yet i'm like man i gotta i gotta
i gotta focus on myself i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna volunteer for that two
spot under the boat man i'm i'm hurting
right
and so
after
post hell week
i failed a evolution called life
which sometimes is a pass or fail
sometimes it's weed out evolution
and uh so life-saving just for people to
understand this is where
the students have to rescue the
instructors who are allegedly drowning
and they're actually not drowning
they're actually just getting ready to
kick your ass
so and they have different levels the
first one is kind of passive and then
the it goes up
those to the fifth level which is you're
you're in a fight with another dude in
the water
and you mentioned that it's pass fail
but
you also mentioned that
there's a decent amount of subjectivity
to it where if you have a guy that's
coming through buds that maybe he's
meeting the standards he might even be
crushing the standards but he's not a
good doesn't appear like he's going to
be a good teammate doesn't it doesn't
appear to be the kind of guy you'd want
your platoon as an instructor
they can
weed that guy out yep at least that's
the way it used to be yep and that that
that that's what it was
and it's i'm glad
i you know i look back on it it's one of
the best things that ever happened to me
um you know i got i failed that event
they they give you like in most
evolutions of buzz i'll give you like
two or three chances to pass it i failed
it three times
so they sent me to an academic review
board when you were when you were
familiar with that
was that just like horrifying i can only
imagine that
failing
life-saving would be yeah kind of like
drowning yeah
yeah it you know it was horrifying like
i remember
we had one instructor who was a very
large man very large man i remember
getting him back to the pool wall
pinning his hands on the side and i was
just smoked
and i got up on the pool deck and i'm
still holding his hands on the pool wall
so that you know he doesn't because
he'll just he'll just fall into the pool
if you don't if you don't pin him to the
wall and so i'm pin him to the wall i
get up
i get out of the pool deck and like i'm
supposed to like crop cross his hands as
i bring him up you know you know what
i'm talking so he can like
so he can spin with his back towards me
and then i can put him put him on my
legs and slowly let him down so if he
was a real drowning victim i'm not
creating more trauma
and i remember i spun him the wrong way
and his junk like landed right on the
pool deck and i heard him go ugh
and this he he was as big as jocko food
and i'm like
170 pound bud student
on my third try and i'm like oh my god
i'm done and went to an academic review
board and uh yeah they were i remember
walking in and they were like all right
young man we're look we've looked over
your record and this is post hell week
this is a post holi me yeah me and my
roommate were both stan i think we both
got re boarded that day with one other
guy
and um they were like oh look you're
obviously tough you made it through all
week but we need the best of the best
here and you're not meeting up to that
standard they were like you failed to
run you failed to swim you filled a no
course and here was here's the big
here's the big one
and you're right you're ranked in the
bottom 25 of your class because in
sealed training even even back then we
were doing pure evals and so that's a
that's a big deal
and so they're like we're gonna
recommend that you come back in a year
and i was like okay
and so
you know that was a tough tough blow for
me because they actually ended up
keeping my roommate who had basically
the same stats that i had was ranked the
same the same way so why'd they keep him
do you know
honestly i don't know but
um they didn't tell me but
he actually made it
all the way to third phase
couldn't pass his final swim and he got
he got booted
and he was a he was a little dude as
well but
i felt really bad for him because he
never went back when you were going
through hell week
what were you solid and hell weak in
terms of mentally
you know i would say
i wouldn't say solid i would say my
mentality was hanging on for dear life
and i think that was you know the
difference between my first whole week
and my second health week if obviously
if you say hanging on for dear life
you mean you're sitting in the water on
tuesday night and you're like
like can we get a little bit further and
you just did that the whole time
basically yeah so
the interesting thing is is that i never
thought about quitting
however
i remember
we broke out sunday night
and then monday night i remember
standing in line with you know the class
you know where they're coming around
with flashlights looking at you and i'm
thinking to myself
i've never been this cold i've never
been this wet never been this tired
and this is awesome
this is no monday night this is 24 hours
in and i've still got another four and a
half days of this no and i'm starting to
think to myself there's no way and what
i was trying to do is i was trying to
eat that elephant
you know in one bite and i mean that's i
think that's probably the thing that
gets most guys
in in in training is that
like when you've got a five and a half
day block like that and you try and eat
it in one bite it's just mentally
overwhelming you know but if you if
you're able to break it up into i'm not
even going to worry about friday
afternoon i'm just going to focus on i
know i get to eat ciao in two hours i'm
just gonna i'm gonna make it to chow and
if it gets tougher than that i'm just
gonna make it through this race and if
it gets tougher than that i'm just gonna
put my right foot in front of my left
foot in front and you just break those
goals down
and that that was something that
you you think you're decent at doing
until you get into the eye of that storm
and you're like
that was a big difference between
hell week one and hell week two for me
but
i i bottom line is extreme ownership i
got what i deserved and it ended up
being a blessing how
were you not
just super freaking angry when you got
dropped i was i was i remember
you know
you probably know uh
dan taber
so i remember talking to instructor
tabor at the time he was he was there in
my board he was the proctor of my class
and you know he pulled me aside and it
was really cool because he didn't have
to do this but he was just really
encouraging he was like hey
don't don't let this he said something
effective don't let this be the end come
back do it you can make it
and he's like and he's like and don't
you basically he's like
um don't feel bad about this just make
it right and that was really cool coming
from a guy like that who
at that point in my life i didn't even
know if you know he
you know cared about because you know
the persona that buzz instructors put on
but it was just really cool it's like a
it was like an older dude who'd been
there done that seal chief
and just a mentorship moment and that
that was really cool that he did that
so then it's trick-or-treat to the fleet
yep give me something good to sweep oh
yeah where'd you get stationed so the
the detailer gave me hey your options
are you can go to japan or you can go to
virginia or you can go to jacksonville
florida
and so japan sounded kind of cool but i
was worried that if i went there it'd be
harder to get back and so and i really
didn't want to go to virginia because i
heard a lot of bad things about being in
the fleet there it's a lot colder i was
like florida's kind of nice
i mean ron desantis wasn't there at the
time but
i'd still heard good things and so i was
like uh hey i'll go to florida i'll go
to mayport and i remember jocko i drove
i drove across country
and uh showed up there and i looked at
that ship and i was like and i knew i
was going to be sleeping on that ship
for the next at least couple year or so
i actually slept in my car man i was
like oh my god dude this is going to
suck and it did it sucked
yeah what are you an e3 at this point
yeah so you check on board your ship
did you get scullery duty out of the
gate like like mess decks yeah
no i didn't um matter of fact i got
hooked up on that on that regard i never
went crank we call it cranking yeah mess
cranking yeah that's cranking and uh
my my rotation didn't come up for
probably until i'd been on the ship like
a year or so and instead of going
cranking i went and did something called
the hab team and we were just
rehabilitating spaces it was the easiest
duty i'd ever had on a ship
i worked for the i worked for the post
office clerk
and uh
like they would just pick a space or two
every week and we would just go in we
would tape off the space we would tape
off everything that couldn't get painted
and we would just paint it and other
than that like that's all we had to do
and they pulled me out of my division so
i didn't have to do any of the
divisional work i wasn't standing
watches
and it was like the it was like the
easiest duty i ever did all my buddies
that were you know in in
the gunners mate division were so pissed
off at me they couldn't believe that i
was getting a good deal so we had this
little gym on board it was probably the
size of this room
no kidding maybe a little bit bigger
what ship was it it was the uss
gettysburg okay it was an aegis missile
cruiser
cg64 and
um there were over like 450 people on
this ship echo so there were two gyms
about this size four hundred percent by
ten rooms 450 and and they would close
it down if like the ship was rolling too
much
and so it was like you would show up
hoping to get a workout in two
treadmills and then you know they were
almost always busy
and you the food you're eating is
garbage you know and so it was like
not only that but you would typically
underweight you would work your regular
day like
let's just say you know uh six in the
morning to
five in the afternoon and then every
single night you would have to stand to
watch you would either have the eight to
midnight
or the balls to four as we called it or
the four to eight and so your sleep was
always interrupted you were always
getting treated like crap in the in the
fleet
and um but it again it was good for me
it's what i needed to grow up and even
in those circumstances i said that
i was immature when i went through buds
the first time
and i still think i'm a little immature
now yes but
it's a progression um and uh
but it was cool because i started i
started looking back on okay what did i
do wrong how do i make this how do i
make this right how do i improve while
i'm out here and even in those
circumstances i think
i wasn't under a boat anymore running
with that heavy boat or you know i
couldn't i couldn't step up from my
buddies in that circumstance but there
were times where we were all tired
nobody wanted to take the watch or
nobody wanted to take the trash out or
nobody wanted to do this
and there were times where i could
practice
you know taking it you know taking one
for the team and that's that was part of
what i needed to do and just learn how
to be that guy
you know when
um
when the team needed you and so and just
grow up a little bit but
so so how long did you spend on that
ship two and a half years did you do one
deployment or two deployments two um
they said the seal instructors
and the recommendation on on my exit
eval or whatever it's called was eli we
recommend he comes back in a year but
the ceo of a ship won't get a
replacement yeah if they if they let you
go to a special program so that they
were like no it's just weird happening
we're you're staying here we can't be
undermanned and so at what point did you
commit to like i'm going back to buzz
i'm to make it
so this is an interesting story
and it it talks about it you know it's
all about
taking taking risk at times because
jocko when
when my orders came through to go to
buds i still had a year
left on my con my current contract so i
could have gone to buds either passed or
failed and then you know whatever
or if i failed i could just get out the
navy was like nope
we're you're gonna re-enlist for another
four years if you want those orders they
dropped that on me the day that i was
scheduled to leave the ship i was so
pissed
and i was just like i can't believe it
because i'm face i'm staring down the
barrel because i i use are you at the
four-year mark now i was at the
three-year mark okay oh so your first
enlistment was like three years because
you didn't get through buds well it was
i had a four-year enlistment but when my
orders came through i was at my
three-year mark got it got it so i had
enough time on my contract where even if
i went to buds failed out i could just
get out i'm out clean clean escape don't
have to come back to the fleet but the
navy is like nope you're signing up for
they they knew they know that how much
of leverage they have on kids that want
to go back to seal training or do seal
training or special program or whatever
and so like i remember calling some
mentors in my life i was like hey man
this is what i'm staring at what do you
think
and i also i was just praying i was like
lord this is the only thing
this is the only thing on my heart and i
was even praying while i was underway on
the gettysburg i was like lord if this
is not what you want me to do please
take it from me because i don't i don't
i want to walk in your favor i want to i
want to be the man you want me to be and
i wanna do what you want me to do but
this is the only thing on my heart
and so if it's not what you want me to
do please like pass me out of here you
know you know
you know send me down the pat whatever
path you want me to go down because i'm
a knucklehead and if if you don't help
me and guide me and direct me in this
i'm going to probably make a bad
decision
and so um but yeah it was still it was
still
the fire still burned you know to go
back
even knowing that if i didn't make it i
was going to be right back
in the fleet so that's one of the hard
things about the navy all all you young
men that listen to this show you know is
it
at least in the marines or in the army
man it's like if you don't make it
through a program you can go be in a
conventional unit and fight bro you're
going to be fighting some uh rust and
some dust in the navy bro
you're polishing some brass sweeper
sweepers man your broom dude
that's bad
and it must have been super hard to
prepare now since you're on a ship
underway two deployments in two years
you're eating food that sucks for your
health chili dogs baby
chili dogs
how did you stay in shape or how did you
get in shape
um
once i got once
i knew that my orders i once i submitted
my package i went right back to hey i
got to drop a bunch of weight i'd gotten
a little bit stronger put on a little
bit more muscle
but i started dropping the weight again
so that you know i could keep keep up on
the runs and whatnot
sometimes they'd let us run around the
ship
sometimes uh
you know
sometimes they wouldn't but you know i
just did anytime i got the opportunity
to work out i did
and uh you know i was hoping that
the uh
increased maturity
was really gonna help me out a lot but
you know i just worked out whenever i
can and i definitely don't feel like i
was ready just because of what i came
out of but i was more ready mentally to
you know go back and i think that was
where my biggest
where my biggest issue was
and so you get back to buds
easier this time or maybe not easier but
you were you were more mentally prepared
yeah it was it was easier in the fact
that i was mentally prepared and i knew
you know i'd seen a lot of the movie
already
um the difference was is that when i got
back the second time right off the bat i
got pneumonia and so i failed so i
already have horrible lungs and now i've
got pneumonia like just ravaging them
and so i failed my first two runs and
like so they were like look
if you fail one more run you're done
we're dropping you and i hadn't even got
back to hell week so i'm like i'm like
oh my god dude i'm not even gonna get
back to where i was
where i made it to the first time
and so thank god i uh passed
my third run and uh got an opportunity
going to hell week and so
thankfully you know i made it you know
past that run made it through whole week
and then but i was on the bubble the
entire rest of seal training for runs
yeah and i was a horrible runner every
time like came in like
you know four three two you know one
second houses yeah exactly exactly uh
was hell week
was it was it better going through the
first time when you didn't really know
what to expect or the second time where
you didn't know what to expect which one
was better which one was worse
for me the second one was much better
just because
um
i think that there's a lot of
you know fear and anxiety going into
something like that that you know has
taken out so many men better than you or
perceivably better than you and stronger
than you and faster than you and
you can't argue with the data i mean so
many guys don't make it through that
um
and so
i i knew i could make it through it i
and i also knew there was a part of me
that was like
i'd i'd only stayed awake for
maybe 48 hours before going into hell
week the first time maybe probably not
even that long probably like
something like that
and so there's a part of you that's like
if you've never done something okay how
am i gonna stay awake how's the body
even do that stay awake from five and a
half days and just get destroyed the
entire time and so there's always that
part of you that's like okay i know they
can't kill me but this just doesn't make
a lot of sense at the end of the day i'm
exhausted i'm tired what would what
would things look like if if i didn't
sleep for five five and a half days how
would i function how
so the fact that i'd already done it and
gone through it i was like i know i can
do this i know that
you know one of the things that i like
to tell people this is how it felt for
me was you know how echo you always get
like a
even today you'll probably get a second
win you'll feel tired and then you'll
get a second win
that's how i felt i felt like every time
like you know five six seven hours into
you know into it my i'd get tired i'd
just wait an hour and then i'd get a
second wind and i'd be right back in it
and that's kind of cool that your body
works that way but
um they also said that your body will
stop like shutting it'll start shutting
down uh functions that aren't necessary
to survival like growing fingernails or
facial hair
i don't know if that's true but that's
what they told us so
yeah that's crazy
and and then that's it i mean you you
make it through buds the second time
even though you're on the bubble the
entire time for runs yep but
you make it through
i make it through
and then
um i'm told
i get orders still team three
most of my class got orders to the east
coast there were only six of us just
stayed on the west coast sure i was one
of the fortunate ones
so you you get through it you graduate
and where'd you get orders to
uh still team three
and did that did most your class get
west coast east coast even split how did
they do that so only six of us stayed on
the west coast everybody else went to
the east coast so i was i felt lucky
dang
and where was team three at the time
what was going on team three was already
deployed at the time you guys oh you
guys this is oh this is ramadi oh six
yeah yeah so what they told us jocko is
it all right
team three is deployed you guys are just
gonna stay here and go to schools and so
it was interesting because i had just
married my wife in between buds and sqt
and so i'm like this is awesome babe i'm
just gonna you know hang out at the team
and like maybe you know sweep for a
little bit and like go to a school every
once in a while we can start our life
together so why don't you move out she
just graduated from university of
arizona like why don't you move out when
we can start our marriage together did
you run that plan through the u.s navy
no no
but
choco the chief in charge of us was like
no you guys are good to go you're not
deploying we've you know we've talked it
through blah blah blah
and so she moves out
um and we move into this little
apartment here in point loma and uh
and then two weeks later they're like
hey uh change of plans you're deploying
uh is soon you're you're gonna go
through see your school and then you're
gonna deploy
and so i don't remember what what it was
that happened but
four of the guys went through seer
school the week before i did and then
they deployed and so
i went through school by myself and then
like flew over by myself
on a like a civilian airplane and i'm
just like oh my dude i was so stressed
out first time going to war don't know
any of the guys at still team 3 but my
instructors have told us hey listen
you guys when you get there keep your
mouth shut do what you're told you're
about to swim with some great white
sharks that's that's basically the the
advice and so i don't know anybody i'm
flying to war by myself i don't even
have any guns
and it's just like you don't know
i had nothing to compare to i i'd been
i'd been on a ship before but i'm flying
into a war zone with no guns like i
don't know what's gonna is the plane
gonna land and like i'm gonna have to
plf out of the plane because there's
like people shooting at us like i have
no idea or no context for what that's
going to look like and then i'm going to
have to like integrate into this platoon
of guys that already did a work up
together
and so anyway
we were what 30 minutes down the road
from
you guys in bravo platoon i think there
were
four or five of us four of us that went
to bravo platoon and so we started
immediately you know doing the new guy
job you know making sure the hummers are
gassed up making sure they're clean
making sure the windows have all the
moon dust wiped off them making sure the
240s and the 50s are clean oiled up
ready for the op
and then it was cool because they threw
us in to turret gunning immediately and
i was like this is fantastic man because
all of our buddies you know are doing
whatever they're doing on the east coast
and we're already getting to go on ops
with these guys
yeah that's freaking awesome and the
culture was and that platoon was really
cool in that
um the rule was this we're not messing
with you
unless we need to and then if we need to
we're going to tighten you up
and
you know but it was just like as long as
you as long as you walk around on
eggshells do the new guy thing
you know we'll leave you alone
but you're gonna you're gonna you're
gonna do all the crappy jobs that nobody
wants to do you're gonna do it standing
tall with respect and you know i was
totally
totally all about that things changed a
little bit once i came into
bruiser the very next pump i'm trying to
think of uh
how many guys came to task unit bruiser
in ramadi you guys got you guys got
salad definitely i know we got sal and
another dude named
sean okay sean h yeah um
sal
was
he he was he's such a nice guy and he
had and he smiled all the time this is
the this is the this is the invention of
normal face
so i had this thing i'd do with sal
where i i'd taken the
the cardboard like entered from the
spools of paper that we would print maps
on yeah and i'd sit there and i'd be
like all right sal listen up bro you
can't be you're like supposed to be a
seal now you can't be having this big
smile on your face you look like a dork
we don't look like dorks
and of course this is all like hilarious
so he's smiling even more and i'm like
okay so here's what we're gonna do you
can't smile if you smile i'm gonna whack
you in the head with this thing and you
know so that i'd say i got ready and
he'd be like yes sir and i go go and he
couldn't he couldn't keep like a normal
face for a half a second i'd have to
whack him in the head but he was a
freaking good guy funny and and just had
a good attitude but he just smiled a lot
and yeah of course whatever you're going
to do if you don't smile you're going to
get beat for not smiling if you smile
too much you get beat for smiling too
much so you're gonna get beat i mean
that's basically what the whole concept
was
when you rolled out but when we when we
get to when we get to it remind me to
tell you a funny
sal defranco story that involved you
in
that must have been good yeah uh so so
you ended up i mean that's still even
for sal for you for you guys to roll on
out on the deployment you haven't even
done a workout before you guys get to go
out you guys get to do some ops get some
experience get to know what it's like to
uh
drive down the road in the middle of
night waiting to get blowed up yeah
which is
which is fun
then
then what so then then the deployment's
over
yeah then the deployment's over
and i flew back on the on the last bird
um and uh
and so what i wonder if we were on the
same bird
if it was the last bird we were on the
last bird i don't think so i was relaxed
so he wasn't there
but
yeah
so anyway i get i get back and it's it's
weird because
um all the guys had already been back
they were already like selecting the new
platoons i was on the last bird so i get
in late
and then uh i remember you know getting
back
me and my wife we we schedule our first
like date night like we're going to
finally get to go out and celebrate hey
hanging out made it back all that
and so i'm we're
she's getting ready i'm already ready to
go like you know that that goes out on
date night
and i get a call from one of our my
other new guy buddies that just came
back with me but he came back i think
before me
and he's like hey
you need to get down to danny's right
now and i'm like what and he's like yeah
bro
we're we're in delta platoon now get
down here right now i'm like no dude
i'm off people he's like eli i'm not
asking you i'm telling you get your ass
down to danny's now
so i gotta go tell my wife yeah like hey
there's gonna be no date night i don't
know what's going on but apparent it
sounds serious so so i'm rolling down
world war iii is apparently broken out
there's a situation it happens to be at
a bar in coronado yeah and so like i
jump in my little green honda civic and
i drive over the bridge as fast as i can
without you know getting arrested and
he's like he's like just when you get to
danny's come out behind the bar i'm like
oh this sounds fantastic he's like yeah
we're in delta platoon chris kyle's our
lpo and i'm like
awesome and so i get there i walk
through the bar
all the new guys that i just like
graduated you know sqt with some of
which went downrange some of which
didn't are now standing at attention in
lines behind danny just getting screamed
at and i'm like holy holy cow dude so
yeah that that was and so that night you
know we were you know
it was the in inductrin in the in
docking the tu bruiser right
and so
this guy
this guy you know he he wasn't there but
uh um it was just yeah it was it was
interesting because the culture had
completely shifted to hey man totally
new
new group of dudes new rules
and uh yeah i i realized real quick that
this was gonna be a
interesting two years and you better be
locked on
like we would come in like we would come
into rooms like the new guys like back
to back like fire hands ready to go
because
you you didn't know what was you didn't
know what you were gonna get hit with
but they definitely
they definitely loved uh
having new guys around i'll tell you
that right now yeah i guess that answers
my question i was going to ask you if
you got treated like a new guy since you
kind of would like had a little bit of a
deployment i guess the answer is a solid
yes oh yeah they were like in fact like
a little bit worse because they're like
you lucky bastard you got to go over
there you didn't even do a workup that
was the thing they're like hey
that didn't count
you're doing a full workup you will be a
new guy for a full two years it was like
roger that
and you know what doesn't kill you makes
you stronger right so it's all good did
you uh did we what what position did you
get in the platoon were you a dub a dub
turret gunner yep and it was it was cool
but i i like to talk about my failures
because i think that's where the gold
often is
chris actually sat down with each and
every one of us with his like little
green
notebook and he's like all right tell me
what what are your goals what do you
want to accomplish what do you want to
do and i said i want to become a sniper
and so
um
he actually
you know and i think there were a couple
other but that was
other guys that wanted to go to sniper
school but that was my number one thing
and so he actually sent me to sniper
school my first as a new guy damn yeah
and i failed oh i know man i made it
through pick and then scout
and then i didn't qualify
um
expert on the the m4 the 200 yard
quality you have to do before you
actually get to go to sniper school and
so i was that was hard walking can you
you'd imagine coming back and telling
chris hey i just blew that and so they
didn't get an extra billet no because i
i failed
so chris wasn't happy about that it
definitely went in the book of woe
and uh
yeah so uh you know paid paid for that
pretty dearly but
you know i mean it you know it is what
it is it wasn't like i was
wasn't trying
yeah the
people i guess it's hard it's hard to
see from the public persona that got put
out of chris of like how funny he was
and how like talking he was and
just like and the other thing that
sounds crazy is the the prank like he
liked to do like pranks on people like a
little kid you know he did
that was when people ask me all the time
they're like so what do you think of
that movie and i was like you know the
movies you know it's decent whatever but
i was like the number one thing that
they screwed up was like
that they missed like how funny he was
and his sense of humor and how he was
always doing something shady always
doing something shady so
but but i guess i don't maybe it
wouldn't maybe hollywood didn't think
it'd be as cool of a movie as if you
know they portrayed him that way yeah i
guess they would have had to make it
into a a like a mini series or something
where they could where they could
develop the character
developed his personality so you could
see all sides which would have made it
more impactful because then you'd see
hey this guy that is very funny loves
his family and
likes to clown around i also can be
totally serious and and has a very has
the most serious job
but you know they got to take all that
stuff and like you said they got to make
it into a movie that's an hour and a
half long and
that's that's what they did yeah they
took like 15 20 years of his life and
condensed it into an hour and a half so
i mean you know that that can't be easy
to do yeah
uh
how was that work up good so i was pr i
was i was running your work up yeah
thank you by the way
my god dude
unbelievable do you carry any wounded
guys anymore uh yeah we actually
dude it was so crazy like um
you know and
it was cool to see you because you'd
come out all the time and uh
um i can't remember which ones which
years you were even out for but it was i
do remember doing like you know seven
click insert in you know
you know hit hit the target and then on
the way next fill
this guy would put half of our guys down
at least so actually i would you guys
would you guys would get tore up by the
op4 all right hey man i think there
might have been i wanted you to win bro
i wanted you i think there might have
been a little bit of uh suggestion from
this guy to make it as hard as humanly
possible just by reading some of his
stuff and but i you know it was
interesting because like you would you
know you do your op you do your mission
and then like you've got another
you know click or two to x fill out and
you know trade it's putting down
over half of your guys and so
you know you're it's already you've
already got your body armor on you've
got like a machine gun you've already
got like you know you're loaded for bear
and now you've got to carry
you know another 250
maybe even depending on the size we had
some beasts in my platoon so you know
maybe another 300 pound dude and it was
just like brutal i remember remember one
time i was getting ready to pick up a
down seal and it was chief d
and uh he's a big muscular dude the type
of guy that was he did not want to piss
off let's and also let's say like he's
not going to be super light
he is not super light yeah he's
he's really heavy and so i and he's a
freaking stud like you just want to be
it like everyone just wants to like do
good especially his guys you know they
want to they want to kick ass for him
and so i had my guns on my back but i
didn't like have it
retention or anything so i went down to
like grab his upper torso and my gun
comes over top and hits him on you know
he was like oh my god who did that
thank god it was nighttime
and you couldn't see you did it and i
got it jaco i didn't take extreme
ownership
because he would have killed me and i
just like
i just we we got him up and we you know
we started moving him but
um extreme ownership might have cost me
my life right there
so yeah we didn't i didn't tell chief d
that it was me that didn't sling my gun
and just smacked him in the face but
yeah
it was i think the good thing about the
way that you ran training was
that there was nothing that i ever faced
that was even close to the training and
i think that's a good thing i wasn't
always happy with you about it i
remember one time you were out at i
think you were out at uh san clemente or
something
and instead of like okay we we do the
day runs we do the night runs we go to
sleep there you didn't let us go to
sleep it was just like okay tst here we
go we're going back into town we got to
go hit this and i'm like oh god dude
well i always thought of like day runs
night runs morning runs
mid-afternoon runs
brunch runs how's that sound we'll get a
little bit of that
and stoner was your tu commander
yeah he was uh he was the tu commander
there from 06 to 08 right after you left
yeah yeah
yep and that's when he got that's when
he got hurt yep he broke his neck
uh
yeah
that happened
luckily he didn't break his spine he
just broke vertebrae in his neck when a
dude fell off fell off one of the other
new guys yep fell off of the
shipboarding and landed on top of him
broke his neck i remember i'm
i was at obviously i was at trade and i
get the call like hey we got an injury
and i'm like all right roger and then i
got like a text from someone's like hey
it's stoner and i was like check went up
to the hospital but thank god he uh
he didn't break his spinal cord so
he was able to yeah put on a neck brace
kind of walk through the rest of
until that was healed up and and still
able to go on deployment
because he wasn't going to stay home i
mean no no well that brings up another
funny story because uh
remember uh
i don't know if this guy's still in
anyway our lt
during that period texan guy
jimmy
yep he uh he made us roll he made us do
jiu jitsu three times a week yeah right
these you know all of them you know
following following this guy's footsteps
and it and so we would we would roll
we'd do jiu jitsu before
um before the day started and uh i
remember one time i got somebody i can't
remember who it was another lt
in a triangle choke and i i was tying it
in good and he he picked me up stacked
me and dropped me on my neck and i heard
something go pop up
and i was like okay
you know and we did a quick timeout and
i was like okay i can still move it and
then we we finished the day i'm okay
like we finished the rolling i feel okay
and then is take a shower and then it
starts getting real real tight and real
stiff and i i'm like man
this is this doesn't feel right maybe i
should go say something so
i made a mistake and i went and said
something and i told chris i was like
hey i did something while i was rolling
i heard some pops in my neck
and it's starting to get really really
tight and he's like okay go over to
medical so medical made um called an
ambu who came to the to this you know
three picked me up put like put me on
like a bed or whatever
took me to balboa did x-rays or whatever
and they're like
you know they're like oh you're good
you're good to go so they they brought
me back and uh but they made me put a
neck brace on
and so i walk in to see chris and uh
and i've taken the neck brace off and
he's like so uh what happened and i'm
like i'm good to go they did x-rays
he's like did they give you anything and
i'm like well this neck brace but you
know i don't need it i'm good and he's
like no put the neck brace on so chris
had the guys paint it pink
and then made me wear the neck brace for
like the next week and i was like even
when we like because we were just
getting ready to go to pendleton and so
he made me wear it out in town he made
me wear it everywhere and i was just
like oh man dude i'm never saying
anything ever again
like i said you like to have some fun
yes
yeah
and then uh sir so how was that
deployment
um it was
you know it was i think it was good i
know a lot of guys weren't happy about
it but um
we started on the syrian border in
al-qaeda we turned over with an sf unit
and the deployment started out by
with our primary focus trying to stop
foreign fighters and equipment and you
know all sorts of money and stuff
flowing in from syria into iraq and so
we did a lot of desert patrols
and you know that
it's not i don't think it's what team
guys really love doing but it you know
it is what it is and then
probably
and we asked we actually spent a lot of
the first month and a half building up a
structure to live in so we called
ourselves seal bees like we had two cbs
that were like constantly telling us
what to do how to build this structure
and so we built that and then
after we got that finished um
that's when
i think the army called and said hey
we're we're gonna we're gonna
cordon off solder city
and we need some steel snipers and
some guys to come in and help us do that
because uh al sauders militia was
killing the iraqi contractors that were
building the wall and so
that's when
stoner
and chris
and several other guys
some were rg 33 techs some some were
comps guys and many of them were snipers
from seal team eight and then from seal
team three they formed like this super
troop
um which stoner was in charge of and uh
so they they went
and left us i think four of them went
from our platoon
and then the rest of us stayed back and
we just went all over you know went all
over the country we flew some humvees up
to missoula
and then uh towards the end of
deployment chris came back and i
actually got to go
and you know be a part of that for like
the last month and a half or something
like that but
it it was a you know it was a decent
platoon but we were all over i mean
instead of operating out of one place we
spent time in
al assad we spent time in i think hit
haditha
rot we we even we even built a new base
in rawa when al-qaeda got shut down so
we were just like transient all over the
place yeah yeah that there's
it always sucks when you're not like
with your whole platoon
it's also there's cool things about
traveling all over the place that my
first deployment to iraq we lived in
baghdad
the whole time but we would go out to
all over the country so that was kind of
you know you just get to see different
areas and we'd stay for day here or two
days here
some random like
sf out station in the middle of nowhere
and hang out with them do do whatever we
can to support and then come back so
that that's kind of cool and then my
second deployment to iraq i didn't leave
ramadi like it was there the entire time
and
that was also cool in a different way so
kind of different experiences they're
both they both have something cool about
them they also have some things that
kind of
you know uh might not be as cool
but
uh what was like the big lessons learned
on that deployment for you as a human
oh man
um
let's see
be you know be flexible
you know be adaptable i i found that
that that was so key in that in that job
is um just to be flexible adaptable and
try and keep a a positive mental outlook
all you know at all times and uh the
other thing too i started to see like
i started to see how
negativity complaining
could affect
the
morale of the group and it
you know
it could be detrimental and so
always try and you know
be you know be a part of
not bringing people down bringing the
group down but just being positive you
know because there was some there was
some of that going on in that group like
um you know some some real negativity
and uh
you know it
i get it i understand why
but at the same time i don't i don't
know that it you know was very
productive in making us the most
cohesive
you know fighting unit that we could
possibly be yeah when that real simple
idea of complaining
and
it's so bad and that's one thing i
picked up from wherever in the teams was
like hey don't complain don't ever
complain about anything don't complain
if you're cold don't complain if you're
hot don't complain if you're been awake
too long don't complain about anything
just don't complain just don't complain
and
you know obviously not everyone gets on
board with that program but it never it
never complaining just never helps
anything just doesn't like if you want
to joke about it
that's cool if you want to jokingly you
know bring something up because you're
going to make you're going to make fun
of the situation you're in man that's a
different thing yeah but if you're going
to legit if you're going to seriously
say
it's too hot it's too cold we're not
getting the support we need this is
like those attitudes they're
just they're just they're just not good
and that's why i always liked that that
team guy that you just never hear him
complain or when someone does complain
when you get when you get the right crew
someone starts to complain they get shut
down you know and
that's a good attitude to have is that
we're good
that is that is 100 where good comes
from that's
that's freaking stoner that was stoner
coming to tell me coming to complain me
about something yeah and me saying and
him saying like i already know what
you're going to say and i'm like what
and he he says you're going to say good
because that's what you say about
everything and it's true i'd be like oh
we don't we don't well we're gonna have
to stay out freaking at this desert
warfare training facility for an extra
two weeks good we're gonna get better at
whatever it is yeah let's not complain
that's not the deal
uh
so you get home from that deployment
yep
and it's another platoon because you're
a new guy still kind of now you're one
cruise wonder one and a half cruise
wonder
there's always something man did you go
did you end up going back to sniper
school i did yeah
where when you got home yeah so
thankfully i i just got to go qualify
and then i got to pick up where i left
off
i learned a little trick that really
helped me you know how on our pistols
you you know front sight focus you have
that little green dot and whatever or
the little
white dot
well i was like i was looking at the
front sight post on my you know m4 iron
sight and i was like it's just straight
black i mean aim small miss small and i
was like i took a little paint pen and i
just put the tiniest little white dot on
my front side post and that really
helped me to like put it where i needed
to and just i started doing a lot of dry
firing and the positions that i was
going to have to shoot and
did well on the test and then
went out this went out sniper school i
did really good on the shooting but i
was really bad at the stocking and i was
like on the bubble the entire time and
uh
but you know made it through sniper
school
got my sniper suite
and then uh unfortunately by that point
in 2010 we went to fallujah
and um
they wouldn't allow us to take
sniper weapons on office they were
trying to de-escalate the war and
snipers don't typically do that they do
typically throw gasoline
on things so
so so that were you still a pig gunner
in that or
lead navigator as well i was also
running ordinance department so
yeah i mean it was it was good um
you know and i was i felt it for the
first time i felt like i didn't feel
like i was some great operator but i
felt like
i felt
confident
for you know because it takes a while i
mean there's so much that you there's so
much from like
comms to you know understanding maps to
you know the the physicality side of it
to you know small unit tactics that
you're trying to pick up and learn but
in the in special forces you'll spend
two two weeks doing this
and then you'll spend a month doing that
and then sometimes it'll be four months
before before you shoot your gun again
you know and it's like
so i feel like um by that point you know
in my service i finally felt like i was
you know
okay i feel comfortable doing this i
feel like i'm decent at it you know
the learning curve of doing platoons
i think exactly correlates to the
learning curve of having children and
your first kid you have no idea what's
going on you're a total idiot and but
you learned so much by your second kid
you're like okay we we kind of got this
by your third kid you're like i'm dialed
i'm ready by your fourth kid you're like
i got this like
we're making happen
but you see guys in their first platoon
man it's a lot of it's a lot of stuff
especially nowadays like when i was in
my first platoon it was like okay you're
radio man there's a three radios like
it's it
it was just we weren't doing nods we
didn't have lasers on our weapons
everything was easier and guys now they
have a lot more to learn just even with
the technical side they have more to
learn and then from the operational side
there's more to learn that's the way it
goes um
so that what'd you do on that deployment
so so as you're as now we're ds cleaning
is this like 2010 now yep it's 2010
we're de-escalating uh we were partnered
up with fallujah swat team
we were still doing you know some da's
here and there we were doing a lot of
fed with them making sure that you know
they they knew what they were doing and
we actually started
me and one of our jos kind of ran the
fed and we were just making sure we were
trying to turn more and more of the op
over to them so by the time
by the time that platoon was over with
um
we would go on an op and there were only
allowed to be four seals on the ground
you had to have for every one seal i
think you had to have five iraqis that
was the ratio it had to be
and so the
you know the closest call i ever had was
uh
a night where we got ambushed by three
dudes and uh
we only had four seals on the ground
we had we had i think
two three gun trucks so we had three
rg33s with those remote weapon system
the remote 50 cals
but yeah i mean it was it was
interesting getting you know in an
ambush like that where you only got four
dudes and then a bunch of a bunch of
fallujah swat team guys and you're like
you know
at one point
uh
our aoic at the time
he was like he was on my side of the
street
just give us like give us start to
finish a little bit okay um so it was
really interesting jocko because as we
were turning over things
to the iraqis so that they could
hopefully stand on their own once we
left one of the one of the very last
things that we turned over to them was
um the actual coordinates for the target
we were going to hit and as a point man
i was sharing that responsibility with
another
another one of my you know another
another guy in that platoon and so we
were we were like doing blue and gold
shifts it was my night and so they gave
me like hey this is the this is the
eight digit grid we're hitting these are
you know maps
you know uh of of
the area that we're going to we're
actually going to abu ghraib
which is like a suburb of baghdad
and uh which is like a 45-minute drive
from fallujah and so
they were like notoriously nasty part of
the city yeah like the prisons there
that everyone's heard about abu ghraib
prison but it's also like a part of town
and it's it's notoriously a pretty bad
part of town yeah it was a real bad part
and um anyway so
they
i can't remember who told me but they
were like hey eli this is the first
night we're going to give these guys a
great coordinate so i want you to walk
over there
with an interpreter
what you know go outside our main base
go to their where they where they were
sleeping
the fallujah swat team give them give
them the grid coordinates for the target
we're hitting tonight ask them make sure
that they know
where we're going because they're
actually going to lead lead us out
and so i walked over there i gave them
the you know the grid coordinate i gave
them all the maps and pictures i was
like do you guys know where this is and
they're like yeah we know where this is
and so i was like
and at the time we did you feel funky
about that very and it this made it
worse too we knew we knew that there was
one of them that was every time we left
the wire that he he was calling
and telling people which direction we
were headed so
you know you you always you always feel
really really shady about that and so
gave it to him
and then probably at like one in the
morning or something we took off
started driving driving there and uh i
noticed soon as we drive into the
neighborhood there's like
sirens on in all over the neighborhood
and like like we're already blown
and so we
we did like a video a video drop off
like a vehicle drop off like 600 yards
from the target because the rg's are
pretty loud and we didn't want them to
hear us like foot patrolling in or the
vehicles
and so we get out and there's four seals
on the ground and then there's like 20
fallujah swat team members and we we
start taking off and i'm also point man
that night so
it's like a 600 it's only a 600 yard
patrol into target and so we're walking
down this really really wide street and
so i put us into uh like a file
formation so that at least a couple of
us can engage if we get a contact front
and so we're walking and probably
halfway to the target
um and i noticed that like a staggered
file you said five you meant staggered
i'm sorry yeah okay all good i'm just
trying to trick make sure i'm tracking
no no thanks um and so we're walking
and uh
and i'm noticing as i'm walking because
you're always when you're patrolling
you're always looking for like cover
concealment hey if we get contacted from
the front where can i duck into is there
a wall or a door or something i can and
i notice everything's boarded up bars
everywhere nothing nothing is open and
so
halfway there
all of a sudden dude three dudes with
one had an rpk machine gun and then the
other two i think had aks
but we had a we had a predator overhead
we had i think two apaches and we had a
ac 130 gunship over i'd never we'd never
gotten that much air in any op i'd ever
been on
and so
three guys opened up on us and it was
surreal because the guy with the rpk
no kidding had probably 200 rounds
belted together of tracer so it was you
could see every bullet flying over us
and
you know in training
you're taught okay you hit the ground
make yours make yourself as small as
possible make yourself a small target
and then return fire gains fire
superiority and then somebody's gonna
you know
we're we're gonna maneuver whatever the
call is gonna come out it's gonna be and
so
i remember hitting the ground
and just watching you know tracer rounds
fly over us for probably a minute and a
half before he had to reload and then i
could see the other two
the other two guys muzzle flashes i'm
thinking to myself
i thought you know what if i can see
their muzzle flashes even though i have
a suppressor on my gun because they're
shooting high i was like if i open up
right now and they the suppressor
doesn't work as well as i hope it does
and they they pinpoint my location i'm
dead because it was when we went back
and looked at the footage from the pred
feed it was only 110 yard engagement so
it's very close
and um
so i did were they in a building were
they on a roof or something or not they
were coming they were coming around the
building so i got to watch like so they
were external so you could actually see
them even from the pred because they
were outside you could see them from the
pred i couldn't see them you know even
on nods all i could see was their muzzle
flash
and uh
so anyway
like i wait and i notice that the the
lull of the fire dies down and so as
soon as it dies down like i get up and
i'm like i said i'm really slow so but
i'm i'm running back you know i must
have been cooking echo
and i'm like i'm moving as fast as i can
and i'm pretty i'm pretty light i only
have i think four mags on me you know m4
mags on me and i'm running back and yeah
aosc's over here and he had found he's
like i got i got an out i got an out and
that for us means hey man i got some
cover come over here
and so i come over and i start i bump
him off
and then you know start
i start returning fire
and the gun trucks by this point pull up
next you know next to me and then
um this fight i don't know goes this gun
fight goes on for
i don't know maybe maybe another couple
minutes and then the gun trucks start
you know blasting these dudes with 50
cal and it like ends like that they're
like no we're done
but it was it was um
it was interesting because
like
the the aoic was like hey let's flank
let let's let's and i i was just
thinking to myself i was thinking to
myself hey we were already blown when we
came in these guys knew the gig was up
they knew we were coming here because
there were sirens all over the place
we've got a bunch of our you know
fallujah swat team guys we know at least
one of them is working on the other side
and they're not like a they're not a
good fighting force at all i'm like i
was like bro i don't think that's a good
idea
and um i say we hold what we got and get
the hell out of here and uh thankfully
you know and i don't know how it would
have worked out if we would have done
you know what
what he wanted to he was just being a
hard charging you know
oh who was he was he wanted to make
moves and you know go just
smoke these dudes but
i had a real bad feeling about it and so
you know thankfully he was like he
listened to me and he was like let's
hold what we got and we you know jumped
in the trucks and we got the got the
hell out of there and then it was crazy
because
because believe it or not it was
actually
um
a
iraqi policeman that ambushed us
and so then they roll up
and it's like this it's gets this heated
exchange like what wtf are you guys
doing
you know because we we had to pass you
know how that works where you have to
pass up to you know they're higher up
say where we're gonna be operating so
there's deconfliction that goes on
and uh it got really it was starting to
get a little tense and i remember there
were we had some guys in the trucks
you know just some shooters in the
trucks i'm like hey you guys get out of
those trucks
if this goes down we need to we need to
make sure that we finish this
and so
anyway
nobody got nobody got hurt on our side
which i couldn't believe because like i
was watching hundreds of tracer rounds
streaming to my chief's position i
thought he was done because he didn't
come up over comps for probably
40 seconds to kind of make a call on
what what he wanted but
anyway we got back we drove back to
fallujah after that and it was kind of
wild because
the roic at the time
who was actually who was actually my
swim buddy and buzz and a really good
friend of mine
he
you know
thankfully he didn't bring this up in
the debrief but
he was like uh he came to me in the team
room he's like he like
what were you doing
what were you doing tonight and i'm like
what are you what are you talking about
dude
he's like
i was screaming at you from inside the
rg 33 to get back because i was once i
bumped that guy out i i came out on the
left and i started trying to engage
their muzzle flashes with my laser
and uh he was like uh he's like bro he's
like the wall right behind you rounds
were exploding right over your head they
had a total beat on you they were just
shooting like a foot high
and i was like dude i'm sorry bro i
could not hear you and that's one thing
i learned on that deployment is that
those cool silence that we have
that like work as comms pieces but also
ear pro
you can't hear the crack over your head
because they cancel that anything over
like 105 decibels or whatever they were
cancelling it out so i couldn't hear it
i didn't know they had a beat on me but
um you know thankfully
you know uh
it works out shoot too well thankfully
moose shoots a little high at night
thank god man but
but yeah that was that was interesting
that
um
because because of the situation and we
had so many jundies or you know iraq
fallujah swat team members with us um
it really limited our ability to
do stuff when we needed to
so
you wrap up that deployment yeah um
and then what's your plan
because now you've got two platoons
you maybe could do a third platoon you
maybe could go to training cell or trade
debt
maybe
you know what's your options what are
you looking at what do you make up your
mind to do yeah
so i was looking at a couple different
things my body was pretty tore up at
that point i i'd hurt my back really bad
you know weightlifting
and i had
the navy wasn't able to diagnose it at
the time turns out once i got out of the
navy and went to like a civilian dock
like laser spine institute in phoenix
they were like hey man you got
um you know you got some stress
fractures in your spine you've got some
you know some stuff going on we can
either give you a fusion or we can just
give you shots and i was just like okay
i'll just wait but my back was pretty
messed up at that time it really you
know was pretty excruciating just to
even wear body armor and so i'm looking
at that i'm looking at the fact
that i've kind of done what i came to do
as far as like i wanted to go serve my
country
um and
and i had little you know i was kind of
watching my little kids grow up in
pictures or my oldest grow up in
pictures and i was just like man you
know that was kind of tearing tearing at
me a little bit and so i was like i was
like i'm either gonna go
um through our like aso program
i need something new if i'm gonna stay
and do this i'm gonna either need to go
like aso
or
screen or something but i'm not you know
i need to you know i need to some change
and so
i started thinking about it i was
definitely praying about it and uh while
i was on that deployment i actually was
like but i want to make sure that i give
myself enough time to make a good
decision
because my family's counting on it and
so i actually re-enlisted on that
deployment and
at the time you could give your kids the
gi bill if you re-enlist it you had
enough time in
um and you know uh and so i split i i
gave my daughter my gi bill and relisted
for four so that i had enough time to
plan the exit and at that point i i was
pretty confident that i was done you
know
you know deploying and i was i started
focusing on okay
i need to i need to
exit
and
i did i did you know talk to some folks
about aso i looked at it a little bit i
never really looked at screening
um and then as i i went to the
recruiting directorate after that so
that's when you got home from deployment
yes you went to the recruiting
directorate i don't even know what that
is right
no most people don't um so when i came
into the nsw recruiting director yep got
it when i came into the teams
we only were filling 60 of our billets
at the schoolhouse so
that's why guys like me could come you
know i knew guys that went to buds three
or four times
but now if you even if you come
well
i'm working off old information but when
i was at the recruiting director even if
you like were an olympic athlete and you
came in there and you crushed the screen
test like it never been crushed before
earliest spot you were getting was nine
months out
you know and so um what what the navy
did was
and the reason i took the job is because
my old platoon chief
and old um you know master chief
uh jt you know jt yep
he uh he said hey eli if you come work
for me i'll let you go to school in the
afternoon so you can finish up that old
degree start work toward working towards
getting out and i'm like that sounds
like pretty cool
and uh so i took that job started doing
that
working for him and uh you know it was
it was interesting because the navy sent
us all over the country
they had done a gallup survey that
showed that there were seven different
sports that young men were playing
um that were uh enabling them to be more
successful at a higher rate than
um others what were they
so one was water polo i think two was
swimming and three was wrestling
and that's where we spent most of our
time and it made total sense to me
because like football players weren't
doing well and it made sense to me
because like i was a quarterback
and they were like you know they put a
red
jersey on me like don't hit that dude or
like you know it was like it was so
position driven in football that
and when you look at it like wrestling
water pool swimming you know the types
of sports like that where it's like it
doesn't matter how big you are you're
doing everything
you know and you're gonna be held to a
standard
you know i mean you look at big old
echo or what position you play echo wide
receiver that was a lot smaller are you
going to be kidding me he's only 185
back there oh my god dude we've been
through this a long time holy cow bro
did you like eat a cornerback or
something like how did you get
but yeah like even as like you know as a
wide receiver like they would make you
know you know how it was it was like
okay this is your position this is what
we want you to be good at but we're not
going to focus you in
in in the in seal training bro it's like
nobody cares how big you are what
position you played it's like you're
doing you're doing everything you know
so
those are the sports that um the nsw
director was trying to raise awareness
but you said seven sports that's three
what were the other four do you remember
it was yeah it was like crew
cross country
um
i think lacrosse
wrestling water polo
yeah yeah so it was though but that's
where we spent the most of our time on
those three
and they would send what they called uh
seal scouts around to those type of
events in high school college and we
what we would do is we would show a
video of like you can't you can't
recruit a seal if you have to talk
somebody into showing up to that and
then they see it for real they're like
no
i'm not doing this
so what we would actually try and do is
just raise awareness like this is an
option for you and then um
and and then leave and then let them you
know self-select themselves into it and
so we'd go around the country doing that
so i did that for about a year and a
half and then
got an opportunity to to go over to
trade and uh be in uh mar ops got a spot
in vbss and i started you know just
learning from the guy who was the lpo at
the time
i actually got to go by his house last
night and have a beer with him and have
some dinner with him but uh
after that is when he left he turned it
over to me and i became the lpo of vbss
and so
honestly that was the best training i
got
to go into entrepreneurship because you
know as you know like you
you have like a hundred times
more of this than i ever did but
i never got put in a leadership position
like that where there were so many
things that you had to account for
so many things that you were tracking on
making sure things are going to be in
the right place and then also
when things don't go
as planned how do we flex what do we do
what's a contingency and so
you know that was a phenomenal
opportunity for me because i was even
running my small business bottle
breacher out of our one car garage in
point loma while doing that and just
working stupid hours but
um you know that was really helpful in
you know uh you know helping me learn
how to be a better leader
but it was also cool to see too just you
know uh being a part of being being on
the other side and watching you know
that the training cycle how much goes
into it
and making sure that these guys are
prepared when they go downrange so
you're teaching vbss and you just
mentioned this is when you started
bottle breacher for the first time yeah
how'd that come about
so it came about um i was actually i
knew i was getting out i probably had
you know two and a half years before my
time was up but i'd watched a lot of my
buddies get out before me that had the
same credentials same qualifications i
watched them struggle like to find
something that they could actually sink
their teeth into
and
i knew that wasn't even an option for me
because i had a daughter or two at the
time and so i was like man you got to
figure this out and so it was a little
bit of fear that was driving me
um but also going back to that identity
early on like
you know i didn't
i didn't want to you know that one of
the things that my brothers used to call
me was a fuck-up they used to call me
that all the time
and i
i'm not trying to throw f bombs on your
show i know this is you know some kids
listen to the show but you know it is
what it is and so
there was a part of me that you know
still had that identity in the back of
my mind like hey well maybe you got
lucky and
became a seal but this is when you're
actually going to show the world that
you are
you know that that f up and so um
you know not only did i not want to be
that but i also wanted to make sure that
my little girls and my wife were
provided for so like i was doing that
you know the vbss
thing the lpo thing and running bottle
breacher at the same time but the way it
actually came about was
i remember my little brother who is a
marine corps pilot he is a cobra pilot
he went he went to the pi
and at one of the outdoor markets there
got a 50 cal bottle opener and he
brought it back and he gave it to me
and i was like dude this what is this
thing it opens your beer no way
try it yep sure enough it does
and i was like dude that's the coolest
thing i've ever seen and uh so i put it
in my junk drawer and then when my
buddies would come out of my house like
watch a ufc or something they were like
dude that is badass where can i get one
and i was always like i don't know man
unless you go to the philippines but i
started thinking about it and i was i
actually went up to la um for
thanksgiving
that my some family members were having
up there and i remember on the way back
i was like dude that thing is cool but
it was real generic just plain brass all
dinged up and i was like but it could be
way better and so i came back and i went
into my garage and i spray painted it
black
and then i i had bought a bunch of
punisher stickers because i made platoon
dvds for my last my last platoon and i
took one of the little punisher stickers
once the paint dried and i put it on
there and it was like
[Music]
i was like oh my god this thing is
insane and so i took it to work you know
the next you know the next day or so i
showed it to my buddies they were like
dude this is maybe the coolest thing
i've ever seen make me one make me five
for every guy in my family and so that's
when the light bulb like came on like
this thing is cool but it could be way
better and nobody that i knew of or any
of my buddies knew of was selling them
in the states and so
it was at that time my wife was she was
running a couple online or one she she
she'd had success with some online
businesses just small little online
businesses like boutiques and stuff
but she knew how to work you know the
store the internet and she graduated
with a degree in you know biz business
from u of a
university of arizona so
she was definitely had that part down
where i was extremely weak and i was
like babe
babe do you think you can help me sell
these online
she's like well let me do some research
and you know i'll let you know and so
she comes back and she's like yep i know
what we're gonna do
she's like we're gonna sell them on etsy
and i'm like etsy what is etsy how about
ebay or something i've heard of and
she's she's like no trust me she's like
women
shop on
etsy all the time it's like an artisan
whatever
artisan you know website
and she's like they will buy them for
their men and and so
we started them and the first ones
um after that one that i already had
so i i started buying dummy rounds
online and then i would you know i'd
start practicing cutting them with a
dremel tool
you know just like
crawl walk run right that's what we used
to say in the seal teams all the time i
was like i just have to figure out and i
didn't know anything about manufacturing
cutting metal i was just a dude in the
garage how do i forget that
and so i i cut like i figured out how to
get it down
and this was kind of cool
it would take me it would take me about
i think 25 minutes to cut one when i
started
and they looked like crap but people
still bought them um but then i started
getting real squared away with my
manufacturing and i realized jocko that
the tip of my broom handle that i cut
off with a dremel tool fit perfectly
over a 50 cal round so now i could make
a fixture my first fixture and i cut i
cut the cut into the broom handle and
then i take a sharpie marker and i would
actually draw the cut on there so that
because it was taking me seven minutes i
timed myself to actually like take a
take measuring cloth measure out all the
all the dots then connect them and then
i would take my dremel tool put it in a
vise and cut them
and so that was my first fixture and
then now now we were now we were cooking
right right and so they were you know
they were still really rough like i
would prime them then i'd paint them and
then i was like okay if these team guys
who you know get everything you know
people think they're the coolest dudes
in the world they're willing to buy them
anybody would buy them i just have to
figure out how to market it to somebody
else
so i started thinking okay these are
going to be big in the military units
firemen cops etc and so i started buying
stickers online and i started painting
them and putting stickers on them and we
would market them that way
and it was interesting because you know
when you start when you start selling
stuff typically you want to start your
price point high and then work down
until you find somebody that'll buy it
and so i remember looking at what
everybody else was doing they were
selling them you know like really
generic cheap ones for like
20 you know 20 bucks and i'm like i want
to see if i can start mine at like 28
and make more profit and so i started at
28 crickets nobody bought them brought
it down waited two weeks brought it down
to 24.99
a couple people bought them oh cool got
our first sale
and then you know let it let it hang out
there for a bit and then brought it down
to where everybody else was boom
floodgates open people are buying these
things non-stop and you know we're in
business
and so at that point i just kept you
know working it working at trying to
improve you know our fighting position
or the product
found somebody that was an actual
machinist that could cut them
professionally found a professional
powder coater that could put instead of
putting paint on them to actually like
powder coat them and you just i want to
get one of the old snow freaking spray
painted ones
that's what i want my boy i've got like
i've got like probably
a hundred
bottle breachers from people give them
to me and we have some that we give away
yeah and so i have but i want i want one
that's spray painted with the gnarled uh
cut that barely works that's what i want
i saw one last night yeah my boy uh
my boy mike
um he was the lpo at vbss before he
passed the job over to me and uh he had
one he we broke out one of the old ones
i was like damn i was looking at the
dremel cut knicks and crappy cut and i'm
like god i can't believe it
but you know honestly and you i am big
on my faith and i remember that point in
my life and i was definitely afraid of
failing my family
and you know i was still seeking god in
the things
in my life and i was praying i was like
lord how do you want me to provide for
my family when i get out of the military
and it was funny man when he's like beer
ropers
well
well right but
here's the cool thing man
you know
they are bottle openers and most people
use them to open their beer but you know
the cool thing is is like even something
like that if you give god the glory dude
you'd be surprised some of the doors he
will open in your in your life so you
know um and it's just it's it's crazy
man because um when i told people
especially navy guys they were like eli
what are you gonna do when you get out
and i'm like hey
i'm selling bottle openers jocko
i'm surprised somebody didn't send me to
you
they were like uh
yeah that's probably not gonna work out
man let's get this guy to a
psychological eval asap
but it was cool because
within six months we were my original
goal wasn't to build like a
multi-million dollar business it was
like
hey i want to make some extra money for
a date night or to save up for you know
my next firearm or whatever just some
supplemental income
and then as it started growing i was
like dude this could be something and
six months into it we were doing 7 500 a
month which blew me away i never thought
we'd even get there
and then at that point
i made one of the better moves that
i ever made in business and uh
i sold my chopper i had a motorcycle
that i used to
drive over to your gym and do jiu jitsu
with but
um
and uh i sold the chopper and i bought a
laser i took the funds and i bought a
laser engraver
and that is when things just would
because
i was watching an episode of shark tank
and
um
these the sharks were tearing apart an
entrepreneur primarily kevin o'leary who
became one of my
um investors and he's
he was ripping apart an entrepreneur
because this guy
he had decent cells he had a pretty cool
unique product but he had no brand
recognition on the product so
like he had the brand on the packaging
but as soon as it left what was
happening was the product it was like a
green neon suit that you would wear at a
football game or like a ski you know
like skiing or something made you stand
out right and the guy kevin and mark
there's a market for that
for a green neon suit like a skin-tight
suit yeah like spandex suit exactly yeah
and so the guy had he was doing 300k in
sales and you know annually i've never
seen a human in a green neon suit i'd
never seen one either but he he had this
he had the sails he had the product
there and kev they were looking at it
and kevin's like you know he's like is
the brand on on this anywhere and the
guy's like no he's like kevin just
starts ripping him up he's like this is
the dumbest thing that you know you can
do as an entrepreneur he's like what if
what if somebody's looking at it and
outside the package and they want to
know who made it but they can't find
your brand on there anywhere they can't
go google it and look it up online
and so i was sitting on the couch with
my wife jen and we because we had two
small kids i was in the navy still and
we were running bottle preacher there
wasn't a lot of free time but
we did allow ourselves like that was our
like you know one show that we'd watched
together and i was like babe we got to
figure out how to get bottle breacher on
each and every one of these units sleep
in the garage and so i started doing
some research which led me to laser
engraving
and so i had about 30 000 in the bank
from like a re-enlistment bonus and i
was like i don't we're getting out of
the navy i don't want to risk you know
our little nest egg on something and
unknown right
and so i was like i'm going to sell my
bike and san diego's the best place in
the world to have a motorcycle i mean
just the best place
and and so that was hard for me to do
but i later read rich dad poor dad with
robert kiyosaki and he talks about all
the time
you know um
and and you know he talks about
his book rich dad poor dad what what
what the rich teach their kids that the
poor don't
basically the summary is you know
wealthy people teach their kids to buy
assets
not liabilities right assets something
that makes you money liability something
that costs you money
and i hadn't read the book at the time
but that was basically the move that i
made and you know by doing that our
sales went from 7 500
at the six month mark to a month and a
half later we were doing 22 000 a month
out of that same one car garage to the
point where like i couldn't keep up with
it i had to start like moon like
bringing guys in from the military that
were like you know doing whatever job
and they'd have they'd work in the
garage and help me out and then you know
um i think
you know a year after that point we were
doing 80 000 a month out of that one car
garage and that's when i pitched a shark
tank
and uh
so you were still on active duty when
you pitched a shark tank i was yeah i
was i was you must be at the table at
the end okay i was right at the tail end
and there was an open casting call down
here in like mira mesa
and uh i was sitting with one of my
advisors in l.a and he's like eli you
got to get on that show and so found an
open casting call went down there they
were like hey first 500 people get get
to pitch to an uh casting member and so
i went got in line at like one in the
morning i was like number like 125.
and then and then uh came back the next
day once i got my little
wristband badge and uh you know knocked
it out of the park
and then they were like within a week no
within that was on a saturday monday
morning they sent me an email they said
hey we loved your pitch
we need you have one week to make a
video and i you know made the video they
loved it we kept moving on and it was
funny because they when you get in that
process they assign you a couple
producers and who are kind of coaching
you through the process and uh they were
like it was funny me and jen would have
to hop on the phone with them every
friday at like 4 00 p.m to have a like a
conference call with them how's the
pitch going where you guys at in the
process
and uh it was funny they were always
telling jen we would practice our pitch
on the phone with these guys and they're
like
jin eli's just not excited
you've got to get him excited he sounds
like he's not enjoying this and i'm like
guys i'm not a cheerleader like
when i need to get excited like all but
i'm not going to i'm not going to raw
rob ross is going by like i'm going to
tell you hey this is what we're doing
these are what the sales are this could
be something
and but you got to keep in mind it's a
tv show so they want you to like you
know they want you to be all
they want that drama bro let the drama
want that drama yeah but anyway we we
got we got an opportunity to go on the
show
and uh we you know it went really well
and uh got two sharks
uh mark cuban and kevin o'leary and uh
you know it just it started blowing up
and that created another
another leadership challenge to uh to
work through so then where
once it came out how much longer did you
have in the navy once the show came out
so i actually pitched on the show
um
i feel weird telling the uh seal
commander this but
i was on terminal leave when i pitched
so that's legal dude is it yeah yeah
totally okay well at least as far as i
know
i've been out of the navy now since what
uh since 2014 so
maybe there's a statute of limitations
hopefully but anyway so yeah i was on
terminal leave so i wasn't even going
into work but i went and pitched in la
and uh
and then
the show
um
the show actually aired the month after
i got out of the navy my final my final
month in the navy so it was like perfect
timing for us
and uh
you know we started we started working
you know we started working you know did
we move back to arizona
yeah as soon as i could even even on
terminal leave i moved my family back to
arizona so
uh what'd you get did you get a building
for production like what you do from
that aspect we did we we rented space
we rented a couple different spaces and
uh we just ran it out of there and it
was interesting because when you go
through that process
there's no guarantee that
even if you go to la and you shoot the
show there's no guarantee that your
episode's even going to air
so this goes right back to kind of like
the
situation i talked about in my second
time
taking those orders coming back to buds
it was a big risk because
at that point we had like 70 000 in the
bank in our business account and i
remember
knowing that
you know if this show airs we need a lot
more inventory we need more machinery we
need to hire some people but if it
doesn't air we just wasted all of our
money
or we're gonna have to figure something
out and so we again we went big we
gambled we spent every last cent we had
my wife who who ran the numbers who's
always around the numbers she was like
hey if this show doesn't air
we're not going to make payroll
you know so um
thankfully it aired when it was supposed
to air and you know i think we did like
450 000 that night of the airing
and that was it would have been way
bigger than that but that we got so much
traffic on the website
i was told it was like 13 000 hits a
second because there was like 12 12
million people watched the show
and uh they were like the the website
crashed within seconds of an airing
on the east coast and so thankfully one
of the things that i learned in the
teams from guys like jocko was one is
none two is one always have a backup so
we had a redundancy plan in place we put
up a banner on the website hey go to
etsy we still had our etsy store people
were still able to buy there and so
we left limped through it and then we
were all like yes this is awesome you
know
great exposure great sales and then i'm
like
now we have to make this stuff
right because we don't call it's not
like we're calling china like
you know and so we were before shark
tank we don't call china around here
that's right that's right man
so um we were making like 135 bottle
breaches on a good day before shark tank
i think when we woke up the next day we
had to make like 60 000 bottle creatures
and we had 20 000 emails to answer and
like people are pissed off like this is
the day and age of amazon man like we're
this little mom and pop shop that was
like we're not making with dremel tools
anymore but i mean we don't we're not
making them that fast and so it created
a real leadership challenge where
you know
that lesson of hey
what we did yesterday you can't say this
is how we we've always done it because
how we've always done it ain't gonna
work anymore and we gotta we gotta think
outside the box we gotta get creative
and
thankfully i mean it took me longer than
i i would have liked to have figured
figured it out but thankfully we finally
figured it out got things up on step and
were able to handle national television
airings and stuff like that and so what
year was that
that was
2014. how long did it take you to get
caught up with 60
bacon of 135 a day three months it took
us three months and people were pissed
man yeah the worst part is if
some people somehow we're finding mark
and kevin's you know emails are shark
tank investors and they're like you i
can't believe you did a deal with this
company these guys are idiots you're
stupid you know and like me and like at
that point in my life nothing was worse
than getting an email from you know mark
cuban like wtf you guys need to get this
stuff straightened out you know and it
was just like i mean that's the type of
thing that would just ruin your night
you know but you know going back to just
like working for chris kyle dude hey
that doesn't that don't cut it anymore
man
you know so i i think it's been i think
it's was a blessing and it's definitely
prepared me for what i'm doing now
there's uh i watched i watched the
they have a youtube video that's like
after the shark tank beyond the tank
yeah beyond the tank and it was pretty
cool uh o'leary you know he was talking
about you and talking about veterans you
could see he's a patriotic guy who's
getting like he's getting choked up
talking about what you guys were doing
and just thankful for your servers so i
thought that was to me that was awesome
to see because i don't i don't watch
that show echo is like uh yes big time
watcher of shark tank yeah did you watch
this like when it happened live oh you
you did it's my boy dude in the game
in the game over there oh yeah
were you nervous before you walked out
there
a little bit but i was more excited i
i'm not gonna lie to you i was a little
bit nervous because you know it's like
you know that you you're about to either
be a
hero or a zero on national television
and obviously too like all those
entrepreneurs like
like they have more you know business
acumen in their finger than i did in my
entire body but i knew we had something
and i knew that if we could just get on
the show obviously it was a
controversial product because it was a
bullet you know bottle opener so i was
worried about that but it was funny
because
one of the things that we rehearsed was
we were going to get each shark their
favorite beer
and then
um you know hand out the personalized
bottle breachers that i'd made for each
one of them and then let them you know
open their beer within we're all gonna
cheers and whatever well
um last minute the prop director guy
he's like hey we're not gonna use their
favorite beers or whatever we're going
to use these beers that we have
backstage and i'm like hey your call
your show whatever you guys want to do
and so i don't know if somebody was
playing a joke on me or what dude but i
went and i you know took my bottle up my
bottle breacher i breachered up and this
thing starts foaming all over the place
and i look at it and i'm like you know
this is like they're opening their beers
i'm opening you know my beer and i'm
supposed to cheer them you know do the
cheers thing and i was just like
whatever dude
i just you know you know take a big swig
of it and it was funny because we start
our pitch and jen like
leans over to me and she whispers to me
she's like
there's beer there's foam in your
mustache
and i was like whatever dude
just charlie mike right let's keep going
dude so we we did it you know and it it
was a it was a blessing and i think it's
led to you know so much so much other
stuff but
um you know it definitely isn't always
roses and one of the hardest things
about it was working with my spouse you
know i mean
you know i hadn't even learned to
barely live with my spouse at that point
because i'd been gone a lot and
um
you know we were both kind of like type
a's like button heads all the time and
it definitely took some learning to we
what we call stay in your swim lane you
know and like
you do what you do i do what i do and
i'm and try not to sleep on the couch
spend a lot of time sleeping on the
couch but you know i probably deserved
it
so you're you're talking about the fact
that you know like uh
with your faith
with
you know you you basically a couple
times in your life at critical times
have been
praying and saying hey look if i'm
supposed to go to buds open the door if
not close it you know i need a way to
help my family
if i leave the navy
open a door i'm knocking let me in let
me let me let me know what to do yeah
serious guidance for you yeah it was and
it was interesting because
after after the shark tank
and i know there's a spectrum here um
and i don't try not to compare myself to
other people but i knew
just by knowing myself
i knew i wasn't in a good spot mentally
like you know
done five deployments
and uh
i'd got i'd gotten out and i felt this
like anger and this rage inside me
and um yeah i tried to keep it under
wraps because like i i didn't think it
was cool i didn't want you know people
to know that like i was struggling with
certain things and
um it you know and then all the stress
of being a dad to young kids and and
then running this running this business
with your spouse who you've just barely
learned to
you know work with and so i felt like
you know i was on the struggle bus i
felt like i was failing as a as a
husband in many ways and even as a dad
and i was laser focused on this business
because i was like took the same
mentality from the seal teams like hey
just go as hard as you can outflank your
enemy you know stand up this team and
you know
sometimes when you're laser focused on
something you start dropping other
important priorities and
when it really resonated with me like
the spot that i was in um
probably
probably two years after shark tank i
think it was 2016.
a buddy of mine here in san diego
who was in that vbssl with me just a
good dude i'm pretty sure he's still
active he was an e-dog and then got his
commission
um and he called me up and
usually when he called me
it was just to talk to me we called
it banter therapy we just you know tell
each other how worthless they were and
we'd laugh about it and then like it
felt like you just did like a you know
an hour long intensive therapy session
or something
and so i was like oh here we go
you know his initials are kp kp's
calling we're gonna we're gonna get
after each other and then you know
you know just see catch up see how he's
doing and i could tell immediately he
wasn't calling to you know banter
therapy give me a hard time
and he's like hey man i got bad news and
i'm like what's up dude and he's like
hey man chuck is dead
and i'm like what and he's like yeah
chuck is dead he uh
he got killed
fighting with the peshmerga you know
fighting isis i think it was yesterday
or something you know like i don't
remember what else he said
um but we got we got off the phone and i
was just in shock because chuck keating
was one of my new guys at uh still team
3 in delta platoon and
like like i was like as kind of a sea
daddy you know like looked after him um
just loved the kid such a such a solid
dude
and went on to become just a phenomenal
seal
um
but it was i noticed how i was in
trouble because
i remember walking out of bottle
breacher and i didn't like i i felt like
i was getting ready to just break down
and i didn't want my staff to see me you
know break down i didn't think that
would be professional
and uh i remember feeling it like i
remember feeling the emotion come up
from my stomach into my throat
and like all right cool let's let's just
get this out and it just like stopped
and it would like i couldn't i couldn't
mourn i couldn't i couldn't shed a tear
i couldn't cry
and uh this happened like i started
walking around the
the uh str the uh
the like mall that bottle breachers
buildings are located in
happened like four or five times and i
was like oh damn dude that's kind of
that's kind of weird
and uh
i kind of it was it was it was so weird
that i started thinking about it
and
that was the first time that it ever
happened and there had probably been i
don't know to that point
probably 15 at least 15 guys that i knew
that had been killed you know in war
and uh he was out of all of them
none of them were closer to me than him
and it was kind of i was perplexed at
why i couldn't mourn
mourn him
and so i started thinking about it and
there's a uh
there's a there's a verse in proverbs 4
23 it says
above all else guard your heart
for from it flow the springs of life
and i realized
i realized that not only had i not
guarded my heart but i had built massive
walls around my heart to where i
couldn't feel anything anymore i
couldn't even feel i couldn't even mourn
like one of my best friends that just
got killed fighting isis and i knew i
was in trouble
and uh and the other thing i realized
was that
that wasn't an isolated incident
like it was affecting
the the springs of life that
as a father and a husband that we're
suppo are supposed to be flowing out of
us so that we can love those around us
especially our spouses
our kids
that they were broke man that those
walls that i'd built around my heart so
that i couldn't be heard anymore like it
was affecting it was keeping some of the
arrows of life out but it was definitely
affecting that love that was supposed to
be flown out and i just knew i was in
trouble and
thankfully a buddy of mine named rick
who loves your show by the way um he
invited me to this this men's retreat
and it was like a christian men's
retreat and i was like oh god that
sounds awful
um
but you know he kept after me for a
couple years and it's called uh
it was called ransom heart it's called
you know
um now it's called wild at heart the guy
that wrote the book wild at heart is a
guy named john eldridge and uh
he writes some phenomenal books but
finally i said you know what man i want
to be a better man i want to be a better
husband a better dad and and all that so
i'm going to go with you and so i went
in uh i think it was 2017
and the event changed my life man
and uh i think the biggest question
biggest questions most of us ask
theologically are
who am i why am i here
why is the world so messed up
what can i do about it
and uh you know i definitely got some
answers to those questions and it was
cool man it wasn't like
there was no religion you know there was
no churchianity
you would think going to an event like
that you'd be surrounded by a bunch of
ned flanders
types but it was just a bunch of regular
dudes
um who all came with the same questions
that i had and i think
and i think many of them were in the
same spot that i was they hadn't taken
care of their heart they hadn't guarded
their heart
and um that in the scripture it also
um i think it's first peter 5 5 8 says
be alert and of sober mind for your
enemy the devil prowls the earth like a
roaring lion looking for someone to
devour and i have seen
a lot of men devoured
i mean we got 22 vets every day
killing themselves and that's just
the states that report it and that's
just one that's just one area
um
of of devouring going on
and
you know it's like i've always and i
know that not everybody believes the
same things that i believe i i totally
get that and i respect that
but i've always believed that if like if
you if you get something good
and you don't share it with other people
if you have a life altering experience
and you don't point others to it
that's pretty messed up and you're not
being a team guy at that point and so
i want to share that with people because
i realize there's a lot of dads out
there and a lot of husbands out there
and a lot of
you know vets out there and first
responders out there that have a lot of
questions and they're dealing with a lot
of stuff
and like me
many of you have tried to like stuff it
down like a beach ball under the water
and you can hold that beach ball down
under the water for a couple sec you
know a couple seconds maybe even a
minute if you're strong like echo over
here but sooner or later man that
thing's coming up and if you don't take
care of it
it's going to explode and usually on the
people that you love the most
was there was there uh
like
concrete actions that you took when you
got home from the retreat yeah there
were
the first thing i did was i apologized
to my wife
the very first thing
because
i realized just
and this goes back to extreme ownership
man
i realized how many just how many ways i
had failed her you know
and how she needed me
she needed to she needed me to fight for
her
and of the time
i was so proud jocko and so screwed up
in so many ways that half the time i
couldn't even apologize to her if i if i
screwed up man
and i was broken and you know i needed i
needed fixing and
one of the first things that you you
need in that situation is to realize hey
man i'm broken and it's okay to get help
it's okay
you know to seek it out
that and that that's not how team guys
are trained to thought we're taught to
btf
charlie mike figure it out keep moving
forward
you know and and we're not we're not we
try and stay away from medical we try
and stay from stay away from any of the
touchy-feely emotional stuff because
we got stuff to do and
that stuff's typically not help helpful
but i can tell you after going to that
going through that ministry and i've
been many times now over the last
several years but
my marriage i never thought
my marriage would be great i actually
have a great marriage now man and so
much of it was because
i i was equipped to not go back into my
own story and get some healing but also
get some tools on how to move forward
um and just understand that the bigger
perspective of this story that we live
in man and you know it's like one of the
things they teach there is that
you were given a masculine heart for a
reason because you were born into a
world at war and i think a lot of the
stuff that we see in society
has spiritual undertones and foundations
to it and if you don't like if nobody
ever teaches you that stuff man it's
it's kind of like getting shot at from
and you have no idea where you're
getting shot at from there's a lot i
think there's a parallel there but the
first thing i did was apologize to my
wife
and the second one of the second things
that
uh there's another scripture and forgive
me i don't remember exactly which one it
is but the scripture is i stand at the
door and i knock and whoever hears my
voice and opens the door
i will come in and eat with him and and
he with me
and that's what i needed man i just i
just prayed and i gave it up and i said
lord i'm broken i'm hurting on the
inside and i'm inviting you in to come
rip all this stuff out of my life and my
heart that i don't need that's dragging
me down
and that's not helpful to my family to
those that you've entrusted me to love
and take care of
and i need i need your help and it kind
of goes from trying to do it on your own
to being like hey lord come in here and
help help me with that
and i say that respectfully man because
again i know that pete a lot of people
don't see things the way i do or feel
this feel the same way but again i'm not
trying i'm just trying to help other
people because i know there's a lot of
dudes out there
asking the same questions that i that i
was asking and they want relief and they
want to be well
and they don't know how to they don't
know how to do it
yeah well there's a
there's like a route to humility that
you're talking about and there's a bunch
of different routes to humility and i
was actually thinking about that earlier
today you know like the
one of the
one of the founding tenants of
christianity is hey i'm gonna put
god above myself
well
that's that's that's that's humility to
put you know i i talk about humility
oftentimes from a leadership perspective
you put the team above yourself you put
someone else's plan above your own plan
that's that's a form of humility and
extreme ownership is
you you can't be you can't take
ownership without being humble enough to
say oh this this
this problem was my fault so i think you
know the the the route that you take to
get to a point where you can say okay
i'm gonna be humble i'm gonna look at my
life and say hey
hey wife of 10 years
i'm sorry that i haven't been as good as
i can right that what what it takes to
get you there
is
you can you can take a bunch of
different paths to get there but
humbling yourself
whether it's before god whether it's
before your team whether it's before
your wife and saying hey i know i can do
better that's a path that is going to
help anybody
and and i think how you get there
there's a bunch of different ways and
the result is going to is going to bring
you to an area where you are going to
find improvement yeah yeah no agreed and
i definitely
um needed to be humbled you know and uh
all the guys that are a part of that you
know that ministry john morgan bart man
thank you guys so much for everything
you've done because i i know it's not
just me i know that they've helped
thousands of dudes through it and
if you guys want to go check it out just
go look up you know wild at heart i
think it's wild at heart.com or whatever
but man wow just a life-changing uh
experience for me and it really i went
from wanting to build the biggest
baddest veteran-owned company in the you
know in the united states to uh you know
wanting to focus on my family more
and
and also just coming back to okay god
you know you've blessed me you've
blessed me with so much
how do you want me to spend the rest of
my life like
where do you where do you want me to be
what do you want me to
you know be doing and
um and uh
now here i am man you know doing
something that i never ever thought i'd
be a part of but
i think that's what happens when often
you turn it over and be like whatever
you want me to do just open the door and
if you don't want me to do it please
shut the door
you know but uh i definitely want to
spend spend the rest of my life trying
to help
you know help people and and and guide
them towards you know
concrete stuff that actually helped me
and through that idea of
serving
here you are now running for congress in
arizona yeah what what
i mean that's just a
uh
like a like a like a masochistic move
right to go and just open up your life
give away your time give away your
privacy
give away uh any semblance of civility
from other human beings right and and
here you are yeah
you're going for it
yeah
um i am and you know i think
we're off
we're off to a good start but i went
into this knowing that there was a good
chance that
um you know the the outcome that many
people including myself
are are striving towards will not
there's a there's a decent chance that
that outcome will not become a reality
but
at the end of the day
i focus on what i can control i focus on
hey focus on your posture eli don't
focus on the outcome
continue to try and be a man of honor
integrity
and and and more importantly be a guy
that's willing to say okay i i may not
have all the experience in the world i
may not even be the best candidate but
this country's in massive trouble it's
in massive trouble and i'm willing to go
serve again and if you all don't want to
send me i'm cool with that
if i'm not if not if i'm not a good
enough candidate i'm cool with that
what i'm not cool with
is sitting on my couch complaining about
it and yelling at my tv and i'm not
gonna be okay
i like to i don't know if you do this
shako but i like to think about
sometimes
you know from a legacy building
perspective like i like to think about
my funeral like who's gonna show up
who's not gonna show up what's my what
are people gonna say about me when when
i'm gone are they even gonna be talk are
they even gonna are they even gonna talk
about me
or or bring up my name and you know i'm
i'm hoping that at the end of my life
people show up to my funeral and be like
you know what
eli did some you know
eli was a good dude and he loved he
loved people and he wasn't willing or he
was he was willing to sacrifice and
serve something bigger than himself
and if if if that's what people say
about me when i'm dead and gone and six
feet under then to me i've lived a
purpose-driven
life something that i can be proud of
and to me that's that's what this is all
about it's like
you and i swore an oath
to
protect and defend this country from
foreign and domestic threats and right
now i don't i don't know how you see it
i believe we have some very dangerous
foreign threats out there
but i think the biggest threats in this
country right now are within
and the fact that we can't
we can't unite
and we can't we we have a lot of forces
working against us who i don't believe
actually want
to see a free and prosperous people that
still
um
have the power where our government is
of for and by the people
but there's a dichotomy to that
we have we're so free and so prosperous
here
that
many of us have become complacent
we've checked out we don't think that we
have to participate
and you can't have both you can't have a
government and a country that's uh forum
by the people and have a complacent
people that have checked out and don't
participate
and i think that's one of the reasons
we're in the spot
that we're in because people don't want
to deal with the negativity that goes
along with politics they don't want to
deal with the nastiness i totally get it
but
that's one of the reasons we're in such
a bad spot because we just think that we
can elect these these individuals who
look good and they sound good they put
on the suit with the little
flag on the on the collar tell us what
we want to hear and then we leave it up
to them and then when they let us down
you know we're like
oh well i guess there's nothing we can
do
no there is something we can do we can
get in we can get involved
and we and we can fight for it and
that's what it's going to take honestly
was there any
issues that was there like a straw that
broke the camel's back where you said i
i or i got to go i got to do this yeah
there was and it was this last election
in 2020.
for so for so many different reasons it
was it was part the election
what i what i saw happen in the election
but then
it was also watching
people that i thought
were actually
eyes wide open willing to fight for us
do this number
they look left they look right oh i
guess nobody else is saying anything i'm
just going to get back in line and you
know
do you know do my thing and make sure
that i don't put myself out there
um and jeopardize my future political
career and so um
that that was that was the big one for
me because i i believe that there was
massive fraud in this last election
for a bunch of different for a bunch of
different reasons
at the end of the day if we have a
government that's up by and for the
people
and yet our elections aren't tight and
we're not electing
we're no longer electing our officials
um
we're in mass massive massive trouble
and
the clock then starts ticking on how
long in my opinion we actually last
and so i've said this before i'll say it
again i would rather
we not i would rather my guy lose or
whoever i'm voting for lose
then um
you don't have to even question hey how
legit what how how legit was that
because that didn't look right over
there and that didn't look right and
what about this over here oh we're not
allowed to talk about this or we'll get
kicked off of social media too okay yeah
that doesn't smell right
how about how about if we how about if
we have
if we we the people want to actually
audit and check the results of our
election
what's what does that look like
is it is it
is is it welcomed
or is it
or or do lawsuits start flying
you know there's been some interesting
stuff going on
that are
similar to what you're talking about so
um you know jill rogan
who's
do i have to explain who joe rogan is no
you don't really okay so joe
he you know had these had these um
doctors on to talk about kovid and these
these are doctors that have a
non-mainstream media view about kovid
and he just released a statement
yesterday because now we have some of
these old rock and roll people telling
spotify if you don't pull joe rogan off
then we don't want our music off and
and that's a legitimate thing um
so
it's like okay so rogan came out
he released like a nine minute podcast
last night i happened to be driving and
when it came out so i listened to it and
so this is what's interesting
uh i forget the examples that he gave
but one of them was
six months ago or a year ago or whatever
if you said
cloth masks don't do anything
you would be
literally banned and there's documented
people that were banned from social
media for saying that
and now it's oh it turns out it's
actually true and and for example cnn
has been widely reporting that there's a
whole
list of things like that oh here's
here's the another
example is
if you were to say six months ago or a
year ago
once you're vaccinated you can't catch
covet and you can't spread covet
and if you would have said that there's
people that were banned
from social media for saying those
things and now you look up
and those things are actually true
they're factually true that's what's
happening
and you get this um
with the with the election results that
you're talking about in
2020 there's
[Music]
when people said hey
i'm not sure about this election right
some people weren't necessarily saying
there was politicians there was a very
few politicians that were saying hey
not so sure about this maybe we should
hold off maybe we should check the
results
there was
personality social media personalities
that were saying that and they they got
shut completely shut down right not for
saying hey i think we should overthrow
the government but for saying hey
don't you think we should confirm this
because i i agree with you that
to me the worst outcome
for a for an american election
is people look at it and go i don't
believe it right even if it's a even if
it's
never mind half the popular i don't want
10 percent of the population to think
hey i don't believe this is true i think
that that i think that the the election
results were wrong i think there was
foul play all those things
what i want to do is if 10 of the people
say or one percent of the people say hey
we think that there was foul play in the
elections i want to say
okay well let's
let's get everything out on the table
you know a good analogy would be if
you're watching if you're playing a
football game yeah and
you know a team
we think a team got a touchdown
and and the other team says that wasn't
a touchdown
you don't say well shut up it was
because now we all leave and we don't
really think they they want we argue
about it we fight about it and it's a
bad thing instead what do we do what do
we do nowadays when there's that problem
we solve the problem by going oh
you don't think it was a touchdown cool
we're going to go to the videotape right
we're going to lay everything out on the
table
and then everyone can see oh yeah
crossed the plane it was a touchdown or
didn't cross the plane that's it we can
solve the argument so that we actually
get the truth out there
and
and it seems like
with this election
instead of saying
hey
here's what happened in these situations
here's these anomalies that took place
here's why they took place here's the
impact that they have actually had
here's some characters that did some
things that they shouldn't have done
here's some things that some accusations
were made that were totally false
but but to just say
oh if you don't think that that election
was perfect right then
you you you should be silenced
and and the reason i bring up the the
the masks
and the vaccines
is because
right now it seems like there are some
people that are gathering evidence about
the election that might not necessarily
turn the election over
but they might at least say hey this is
something that happened
this
no one no one agrees that this should
happen no one agrees that someone should
be stuffing ballot boxes right no no no
one thinks you should be stuffing ballot
boxes right so if ballot boxes are
getting stuffed what can we do to
prevent that
and to me
i i can't imagine a uh
an american that's aligned
with
america
like with just the the broad idea of
america where we have freedom of speech
we have the right to bear the the bro we
have the right to life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness i can't imagine
someone saying ah you know what i
actually think stuffing ballot box is
okay i actually
think these these changing these
election laws is i think that's fine as
long as you know it's done for the right
party i that that to me doesn't make
sense right
so
i think when you start talking about the
thing that kind of pushed you over the
edge
i think there's a lot of people that
felt that way yeah
and honestly
there's a long there's a long list of
things that i've been watching for years
but
um
you know i
like for instance
you look at this look at the southern
border right we're getting ready right
now to possibly you know go
send troops over to ukraine on the
eastern their eastern border
um and yet we don't even take care of
our own border right we have fentanyl
and drugs coming over that southern
border we have human trafficking coming
over that southern border
um you know we have we're
we're basically in you know supporting
the cartels by doing that we have ms-13
gang members coming over that southern
border and you have an administration
right now that doesn't even
want to address that problem at all
they're actually taking people in the
dead of night sometimes and flying them
around the country right you had a
situation where border patrol agents
were being fired because they wouldn't
take a vaccination yet
people that were coming here illegally
weren't forced to take a vaccination and
then flown all over the country in the
dead of night so that you and i um
wouldn't wouldn't know about it wouldn't
see about it etc
and those are facts as well and so
that's just one that's just one more
issue how about our how about our debt
situation we've got like close to 30
trillion dollars in debt right
um right now you have nancy pelosi
and others pushing spending bills that
are going to continue to rack up that
debt and we don't even have the money to
pay for it we're just printing money and
basically
we're devaluing the us dollar and were
causing inflation to skyrocket
and you have democrats like the guy i'm
running against a guy named tom
o'halleran who will try and
convince you that inflation you know
it's it's not that bad or it's you know
i've even heard in the in the media
they'll say well jen saki said well you
know it's a you know it's an it's it's
an upper-class problem you know and it's
like um
people that are putting gasoline in
their cars people that are buying
you know hamburger meat or
um you know any of the any of the
consumer products that we buy those
prices are going up and up and up and it
affects everybody and this idea that we
can just print our way out of this mess
that we've gotten ourselves in because
we don't have any fiscal responsibility
and we have politicians that want to
support a you know a spending bill so
that they can go back to their
constituents and say oh well hey look i
just got you guys you know great
broadband you know wi-fi or what
whatever it is but knowing deep down
that there were
you know a thousand other things in that
bill that wasn't good for the country
but now they can come back and hold this
trophy up and be like look what i did
for you guys
you know all across the board how about
energy
un you know we went from
actually having so much energy that we
were exporting energy we shut down the
keystone xl pipeline
and now
we and we greenlit the russian pipeline
at the same time
right so
how's that good for america
we're talking about defunding police
officers are you are you what
what what what universe are we living in
right well that's a good idea you know
and i like jocko what you've been
talking about hey how about we get get
some of these you know police officers
some better training right i think
that's great
but defunding them ain't gonna help
anything it's gonna it's gonna hurt
people and it's gonna hurt peop lower
class people and minorities more than
anybody else
so we've got this country has gone so
in my opinion it's gone so far backwards
and so many different in so many
different ways that i look around
and one of my favorite sayings of all
time is evil triumphs when goodman do
nothing and so again it's just like
i'll tell you what if there was
you know if if you were running in my
district i wouldn't be running in this
district bro i wouldn't and matter of
fact i'm going to put you on the spot
right now
i know because i know i'm not the only
one that has asked you
gavin newsom
there aren't too many guys that could
take him out you could take him out dude
and i know you're building your empire
but i want to put that on your brain bro
because you could take him out
i know you could yeah um
all right think about like think about
the platform that you have think about
your your reputation in the seal teams
think about
what what you've done as an entrepreneur
and at the same time you've managed to
keep your family intact bro
that's that's big time i don't know
another i don't know another human being
that
has that all under one roof man
and so
i know you got stuff to do i know you're
working on stuff but
you could take them out
you could
[Applause]
evil triumphs when good men do nothing
man and i and i hate to even i hate to
even put you on the spot because
nobody's done nobody deserves to like
enjoy the american dream more than you
have just with everything you've done
but this is an inflection point in this
country and that's why echo that's why
you see
seven navy seals running right now
because it wasn't like hey it wasn't
like we got on a conference call like
hey you know be cute as if we all ran
for congress no
no everybody they all realized it i know
you i know you feel it as well
but you know how badass would that be to
have jocko you know the governor of
california
yeah and and
look i i appreciate you um
your input on that one
uh i
really don't want to go into politics
that being said
i you know what's interesting is you
know i talked to all my friends that
live in texas they live in utah and they
live in montana and they live in arizona
and you know there's just been a rash of
people leaving california
businesses leaving california my friends
a bunch of my friends have left
california
and
i love california
california is freaking awesome it is
california has the pacific ocean it has
the mountains it has the desert it has
the redwood trees it has yosemite it is
a magnificent place it is absolutely
magnificent
and
yeah it is in a
very
situation right now
that i don't think it can i don't think
it i don't think it can continue to go
this way
i mean you've seen the news you've seen
the the
the
homeless situations yeah you see the
the trains that were getting attacked
and
you know
robbed from entire freight trains
um i don't know what's gonna happen man
i don't know what's gonna happen in
california i
i love california california is an
iconic place
and there's and the other thing you got
to remember about california is
california is not san francisco and los
angeles that's not california right
that's a small part of california
california is the imperial valley
right california is the agriculture that
is the vast majority of this state
and hard working americans that are out
there busting their ass to make things
work and at the same time paying an
incredible amount of taxes and having
the regulatory environment that's
that's hostile to business legitimately
hostile right
so
with all these things as they continue
to add up
um
i can't predict the future i certainly
hope i don't have to get into politics i
i i really just don't know if i have the
stomach for it
um
i don't want to do it man i i know it's
like just the biggest cop-out that i can
throw back at you at this point and and
you and the rest of the guys that are
out there trying to do it for the right
reasons is awesome
um
man i don't i don't want to get into
that business i don't want to get into
that world and
you know
when people ask me about politics i
always tell them that you know i'm not i
don't want to do it unless things get
really bad people hit me up all the time
is it bad enough yet is it bad enough
yet is it bad enough yet
i don't know where that line is for me
uh i feel a dumb and dumber moment
coming on right now where i just want to
say
so you're saying there's a chance
there's a chance okay
one in a million
awesome
uh
don't like it um no i i hear you i hear
it's an it's nasty man it's a nasty
world and it's a cat dude and i i'm
barely even scratching the surface of it
but even now like
i i don't really like the world i don't
like the self-promotion of going around
campaigning and telling people why
you're so great and why they should vote
for you i don't like that part of it i
don't like the nastiness of
you know people lying
lying about you and trying to smear you
and you know
every single way possible and if they
can't come up with anything good they'll
just make it up i don't like that part
of it
i don't like exposing my family you know
to this stuff as well i just want my
kids to grow up
kind of like a normal life and
but i'll tell you what man it's like if
if enough of us don't do it
we're done yeah that's the way i see it
man and i wish i was more optimistic but
i watched like just like on a uh you
know a dope sheet as a sniper man i
watch trajectories i watch where this
country started and where we're at now
man and it's
i mean covet if if that doesn't wake
people up
you know to uh
you know the fact that
often most often governments aren't
typically interested in
letting the power rest with the people
i don't know what's going to wake people
up but
it's it's getting bad and we need to
we need some sled dogs to put their
and maybe a couple leaders
to put their uh their shoulder to the
wheel but just saying
am i the only one that's ever called him
out on i don't think so no
okay
i will say when i speak maybe not
necessarily on the podcast because it's
a small group of two or maybe three yeah
so yeah whenever i go and talk to
businesses companies organizations i i'm
getting called out almost 100 of the
time good to get in the game to get in
that game you know and and right now i
mean
uh part of my cop-out part of my uh uh
rationalization
is you know i'm trying to build
businesses in america american-made
business we're bringing manufacturing
we're putting people back to work we've
got hundreds of employees american
employees that are that are making
things happen we're we're bringing back
manufacturing
that's
that that's it it is a part it is a part
of the fight it's a very important part
of the fight and honestly that's why i'm
an america first candidate not because i
not because i hate
you know any any other country around
the world but i love this country and
for so long so many of our leaders and
politicians have put america on the back
burner and they've sold out so many
you know of our workers our constituents
and it's just like hey you know i'm all
for i'm all for you know
free trade but it needs to be fair and
we need to make sure that we're not
shooting ourselves in the foot and
shooting you know you know displacing
our workforce and taking manufacturing
away from many of these folks and
families that you know count on it and
that was one of the coolest things about
bottle breacher is that
i couldn't have even done it this long i
couldn't have even run that business
this long if i didn't find a way to
incorporate mission into it okay how do
we
how how is this bigger than just profits
and balance sheets and okay so we can
support some cool veteran non-profits we
can hire some vets we can make our
products in the usa okay that's enough
of a mission to keep me
you know engaged
you know for a certain amount of time
but you know and i i love that you're
doing that as well man um it's it seems
like it's getting hard to keep up with
all the stuff you're doing
well you you took on a bigger challenge
man you took on a bigger challenge
uh so
how can everyone help out how can we
help get you elected what do we got to
do yeah all right um so i appreciate it
man i just appreciate the opportunity to
come and rap with you guys
um
if people want to go follow me they can
look up eli eli crane underscore ceo on
social media if you want to go to my
website it's eli for arizona.com
you know i i hate to even ask but
unfortunately in this world
so much of this boils down to name id
and for a first time guy in in a
political race uh us congress race so
much of it is going to come down to do
we have the ammo and the resources to
run all the tv ads all the digital ads
all the mailer ads etc so if you guys
can give us a small donation we would
really appreciate it
i'm asking people for prayer as well um
you know just for guidance direction and
wisdom and the other thing i'm asking
for is that people share
um you know share
the website share what we're doing here
so that other people that don't know
about it can pitch in and help too so
those are the things that you guys can
do
sounds like a plan man um
probably a good place to wrap it up echo
we've got you got any questions yes oh
we got football questions
i don't want to keep us here too much
actually no i just actually want to say
so when i when i when we saw the shark
tank episode yeah you know how like
because you guys watch that even before
you're on yeah you know the kind where
someone comes out with a product or
service and you immediately depends on
who you are obviously right and you
immediately know like oh this guy's
going to get a deal yep that's what i
felt about yours because brad he bet you
don't watch shark tank i've watched it i
mean i watched your episodes over the
past like a few days when i knew you
were coming out here but no i'm not a
regular watcher bro i'm like like a
bunch of other people the moment i saw
that thing
as a i was like did you know anything
about did you know eli before that no no
i didn't this was back in the day this
was like in 2014 yeah
um but bro once i saw that thing i was
like bro that's the coolest i've
ever seen yeah you're that guy bro oh
yeah you're that guy that he was talking
about no dude it was i mean it was so it
was so cool and such a blessing man and
uh i mean it's still
i tell people all the time you know um
you know guys don't really grow up we
just get bigger toys can i tell can i
tell the sal defranco story oh yeah
all right so it's so funny man
you know jocko is who jocko is man and
you know you got got people that want to
be like jocko right
and it just so happened that a lot of
people you know in in task unit 2 wanted
to be like jocko so
they made us do the older guys made the
younger guys do skits
and that's a pretty dicey situation man
because by the way i know i know where
sal lives right now yeah i know where
he's at so i might have to go get him so
he's coming brother no um
he wasn't even making fun of you
really it was just he was making fun of
people that wanted to be like you
and so it was funny so they make you do
these skits and if you piss them off you
know you deal with you deal with that
side of it but if you make them if you
can make them laugh while making fun of
them that's that's the golden ticket
right so
sal was always the funniest dude so sal
came up with a lot of our skits and so
um i remember he did this skit and it
was like he was playing you
and uh or no he was playing i think he's
playing stoner and he had this he had
this note like this nope this binder and
he put like
uh what was it
www jd what would jocko do and he like
walks out playing stoner talking like
stoner he's like you know all the
acronyms btf charlie mike you know the
guys are just rolling because he's you
know he's like you know making fun of
all these guys who want to be like jocko
but are failing miserably and it was
just it was just so funny dude so you
know that that became you know a joke
you know a running joke after you left
like
god dude all these guys walking around
what would giaco do trying to be like
bro you're not jocko just be yourself
man okay just for yourself
big tough frog man you know
over 200 pounds all this stuff dude
hey what's charlie mike
continue mission oh yeah that's just
another right and it and it's a
unofficial thing
meaning
uh our status this time is that we are
going to charlie mike i mean it's an
official thing like we are actually
continuing the mission but that turns
into just like hey just charlie mike bro
you just gotta just keep going
not official btf is unofficial official
yeah okay
btf is unofficial similar meaning except
for btf has
you know greater capabilities because it
can be used for a lot more things than
just
continue mission
so you know um that's all good it's all
good
uh eli
yep any closing thoughts
thank you man thank you for you know
what you're doing and uh thank you for
allowing a guy like me
you know to come on this show like i've
listened to this show for you know years
and i understand why
you
you try and keep politics out of it
because you know i mean it's such a
divisive thing but
i just appreciate you taking a risk and
bring it allowing a guy like me to come
on and you know talk about a little even
my faith man that's something that it
can be really divisive to people and
i definitely don't want it to be a
divisive to people and i definitely
don't want to disrespect what you've
built but i'm grateful that you allowed
me to come on and talk about it because
at the end bro i do not want to be
i never wanted to be in congress i don't
like wearing suits i don't want to live
in washington dc but
i honestly believe if we don't get if we
don't get some men and women with
courage and character that never wanted
this job in the first place in key
positions
i'm very concerned about what the future
for my kids is going to look like so
thank you man for using what you've
built to help guys like me
yeah well
again um
thank you thank you for what you're
doing thank you for what you did thank
you for job in the teams man
that that that counts bro like getting
after it getting out there doing that
job
holding the line in the teams thank you
for doing that
and for what you did with what you did
and what you continue to do with bottle
breacher
like that's building the american
economy that's made in america that's
freaking outstanding that's providing
jobs for people
that's that's awesome
and and what you're doing right now
going into politics look i don't like
politics
i know you don't like politics and
you know i'm i'm not like intentionally
staring away from politics on this
podcast it's just not the thing that i
talk about normally i mean and i've had
i know other political people on here
i'll continue to have them i've had
people from both sides i've had
democrats i've had republicans on here
people that have run for democratic
positions people that have run for
republican positions
people and you know talking about your
faith like that's that's a why i mean
i've
that's wide open you know you can't
cover books about the military and not
have
faith
in intertwined in those things from
people that have have been to the edge
and back
but for me
you know what i like what i want and
what i hope is that when people listen
to what we talk about here they actually
listen to it actually listen to what
people are saying yeah and instead of
trying to figure out where i don't like
you or where i don't agree with you i
try and figure out where i agree with
you where
you have a common goal
that that i have and you want to see
america move in the same direction that
i want to see it and maybe we have some
different ideas about how to get there
yeah
that's okay
that's okay you know in a platoon you
ask a pl you ask you ask every single
guy in a platoon
to come up with a plan for a mission
they're all going to come up with a
different way and they're all probably
going to think their way is the best way
but guess what we're all trying to do
the same thing
and that's what we need to do in this
country is look at where we're trying to
go
get on board support each other and
let's move in that direction
thanks for coming on man appreciate it
thank you
and eli is on his way back to arizona
and before he left echo charles man you
sir you normally aren't
quite as hyped to get a picture with
someone
as you were with eli
because
as far as you're concerned
uh shark tank is
he's he's he's a movie star for you well
or something you know
you didn't know him at all when you
watched him on it you would just happen
to watch that live like whenever it came
out in 2014
you were watching yeah so i have seen i
do watch shark tank yeah i've seen every
single episode
really yeah yes how many seasons have
there been i don't know one million i
don't know okay but it's like the trade
like just like how eli is like where i
don't really watch tv but there is one
show that me and that's literally the
one show that you like
there's two well hawaii five always does
not come on anymore so yeah that's okay
we're down to one show yeah
um there's some other ones that are like
cool i'll catch it if it's like the tail
end of the night and then whatever but
um the one that we do watch together
every episode shark tank
and that was one of them no i didn't
know
him
but he was like you know i'm a veteran
you know former navy seal and stuff so i
figure okay we must know you know kind
of the same people and
just in general
but the thing that really was like i was
down for the cause is when he showed
that thing man
the freaking 50 caliber bottle opener
bro come on bro i mean not you know was
it the cure for cancer no but
it was the coolest thing i've ever seen
ever
in terms of bottle opener debatably yeah
it was really cool and when you know
after a while you can tell like okay the
the product alone is such a good idea
that he
of course he's going to get a deal he
was like that thought like yeah i
thought oh yeah he's going to get a deal
and he got a double yeah he got a double
d two sharks that's a big deal actually
three sharks bid because one other shark
said i'll do a deal right now and then
eli said hey just out of respect for the
other sharks
i want to make sure that
just does anyone else have anything to
offer and then the other shark stepped
in
and made an offer and then the the other
shark
i don't know all the sharks
so
that's another little detail and that's
fine that's interesting because i do
remember him saying that but i totally
forgot that he was the one who said that
which okay so a lot what was good was
how he framed it i remember that part i
he framed it as not as like
and actually they made fun of him a
little bit because he said he said
he said out of respect for the other
sharks i want to make sure that none of
you would like to make an offer as well
when what he was really saying was hey
listen does anybody else want to throw
in more than that
one of the female sharks said oh out of
respect for us like she kind of called
him on it but but he did it right he did
it right perfect and so good job eli
usually how they say it is kind of like
well it wouldn't be smart for me as a
businessman to you know just like taken
off for the first offer so they they'll
frame it something like that like hey
out of out of like my own or our
business interests about me yeah when he
said out of respect for the other that's
undeniable right there because this is
what the sharks will do sometimes
cuban will do this he'll be like um do
they have their own little methodologies
that they use what's cuban do he'll go
if he really wants it he'll bully the
other sharks so he'll be like this he'll
go hey i'm offering you this this this
but you gotta take it right now like you
start and i don't wanna hear them if you
start taking there and he'll he'll
totally do it too he'll be like well you
know i should think i should hear an
offer from and if the one of the other
sharks starts talking like hey i'll
offer you this cuban will be like i'm
out so they miss it and now he has kind
of a little bit of a reputation for
doing that kind of stuff sometimes so
now people get really oh and they jump
at it you know
but if you frame it like hey out of
respect for the other sharks he would
have to paint himself as a bad guy now
for him to really follow through yeah
that was good
and he seemed so respectable
yeah yeah yeah no he did good
it was cool to have him on here man but
definitely cool and
even though he's trying to get me to run
for freaking governor of california and
stuff
i'd have to do a bunch of campaign
videos oh yeah you got to be a campaign
video guy yeah yeah yeah but you might
even have to work
[Laughter]
i really hope it doesn't come to that
man but but i give it up for these guys
that are out there
doing this because i look i can you know
sometimes people say oh i wouldn't like
to do that but you know they're lying
yeah you know they're like i i don't
want to have to run for this position
yeah the feeling of the need that my
country's calling me and you know that
they're not telling the truth
like you can def eli is like hey i don't
want to do this you can tell eli like
literally does not want to do this no
choice but at the same time you can see
the passion and he knows that we need
help
and he's right he's right man
he's right good on him he came at me
with the direct approach
which is normally not your recommended
approach but
it kind of made me think man uh i'm weak
over here well yeah and even if you
don't and this is all
in a big picture kind of way this is all
just the natural course of things where
like if things get too extreme and
everyone start recognizing wait a second
it's too extreme
it's gonna start tipping the other way
and usually when it tips the other way
just like a swing right yeah it's gonna
it's gonna
tip maybe a little bit more
you know and hopefully it'll settle
hopefully at some point i
am i i'm
keep waiting for california to start
swinging back and it is you are starting
to see indications right there was a
female uh mayor up in san francisco that
she just came out was like all right
we're
we're crushing crime we're funding the
police and she was this is in san
francisco this is like a liberal mayor
of san francisco she started swinging it
back the other way yeah so that's the
one of the early indications of what's
going down i mean you see the
politicians out here just amanda they
did a ma right now it's what date is it
today i don't know but like they got
they put another mask mandate on indoor
mask mandate i mean meanwhile
other parts of the country are wide open
for
months yeah even the denver guy same
deal yeah and a wide open
england is england's just saying we're
done we're done with covered yeah hey
more people are going to get it we know
that uh i think sweden or somewhere else
there's there's places that are just
going wide open yeah and florida's been
wide open in texas then i was in texas
for a couple years ago
i mean it was a couple maybe it was like
a year and a half ago i did a jujitsu
seminar
or like a meet and greet
at jiu jitsu there was 200 people there
rolling jiu-jitsu meanwhile california
was in lockdown by the way
so
that's okay so people are making
decisions but here's the here's you know
i just saw a picture of the
newsome who he was just talking about
at a
football game with a bunch of other
politicians none of them wearing masks
as they have mandated for everyone else
you see
you can't get away with that forever no
you can't it just doesn't work yeah and
that's why the pendulum is going to
start to swing back
that's what's going to happen i hope i
don't have to ride that pendulum to the
other side yeah because i really don't
want to i want to surf i want to do jiu
jitsu i want to make the podcast i want
to build
the companies that we're building so and
and if we can do that properly
maybe we don't have to get into this
whole freaking political thing yeah
so it's like you know if you're in a bus
we'll say or a van say we're in a bus
you know what i fee you know the break
in case of war break glass yeah i feel
like that's my political that's your
favorite and and i joke about it but
like i think it's got to be
i'm talking chaos i'm talking i'm
talking
i'm talking
total mayhem and chaos and i don't
really think i would be a no i don't i
think it's i think i would become a
political leader in an environment when
things
are no longer the way they were
you know what i'm saying i think i'm i
think i'm more stepping up to
a really hostile situation yeah that's
where i'd get that's right rolling hot
yeah and a lot of times too we have to
remind ourselves that or remind
ourselves of the question of is it
really
hostile or is it just hostile like on
the internet yeah or on that tv or
whatever and i'm not just saying it is
or isn't i'm just saying that's always a
good reminder and i will tell you that
there are elements that are hostile in
real life there's definitely ones that
are hostile and i don't think with joe
rogan was just crazy right now you know
and and the points that he was making in
this little nine minute episode that he
did
i mean
people got banned from twitter for
saying
masks don't work yeah and by the way
there was people out there wearing three
and four masks when i was traveling
let's go to the airport there'd be
people with two masks on and a face
shield right and okay hey
cool go go do that
but
some people are saying hey this how does
this work and you know the people like
dude it's a piece of cloth over my face
how's that stopping anything that was
just a kind of a common sense approach
okay well you're banned from
you're banned from talking
even if you're like it doesn't seem like
this does a lot you're banned from
talking so now now you talk about those
election things and it's like hey well
it doesn't it seems like these states
that
were like swing states there was the
voting stop and in the only four like
swing states that mattered the voting
stopped counting at midnight does that
seem weird yeah oh you're banned
you're not allowed to say that yeah what
the right answer should be hey that's a
good question let's do some analytics
and figure out what happened yeah
so and there's i i do know that there's
some other information that's coming out
right now that is definitely
let me rephrase that there's information
coming out about the 2020 election
that indicates that maybe things should
be looked at a little bit more so
and again
if it's wrong
and it turns out that the election was
squared away then cool you go okay cool
now you all can stop worrying about it
all you freaking crazy right wing fringe
trump maniacs can calm down now cause
look here's the facts
but instead what they're saying is like
hey shut up right you're a conspiracy
theorist
what does it do what do you do when you
suppress that information what does it
do to those people it embold it doesn't
embolden them it makes them even more
suspicious
and that's not a good move
when you won't show the nfl team the
video they just go gee they don't even
show us the video that's a bad move
air these things out man what's the
worst case scenario what's the worst
case scenario hey we got we got some we
got to fix our elections a little bit
that's that seems legitimate to me
i want to have everybody's vote count
okay cool don't you
or do you not
because if you do not then we have a
we have a serious problem with our
alignment between us too as human beings
i'm american i think
we vote for our people
and that's who gets put into office
don't you think that
you know and if you don't think that we
have a serious problem
and i don't i think most americans
the vast vast vast majority are like
yeah of yeah whoever gets voted that's
who should be in office cool yeah we
agree on that we can agree on that
should the voting beast done method
where it's kind of
standardized and
makes sense and
it's hard to cheat wouldn't that make
sense yeah that would make sense
okay cool
yeah that instant replay analogy was
pretty much spot on there because it it
does like you know in football
as the example is the if
you know usually it's yeah it's like a
touchdown or an out of bounds scenario
or whatever right where the line matters
yeah actually actually technically it's
never in it it doesn't have to be a
critical moment it can be the first play
of the game the problem is though you
only get so many of those calls you can
only go to the videotape a certain
number of times and you might not want
to waste it if it's like
you know if you've first and
two yeah whatever i think that's
challenging the rep yeah yeah
challenging the rest call that's that's
true so
either way
if
the reason that
exists is because we do
no matter what team you're you're
cheering for san francisco 49ers or the
denver broncos whoever
i don't know
um whoever you're cheering for you do
want to know the truth yeah like no one
wants like
if someone didn't make a touchdown it's
pretty pretty hard for us to be like ah
nah we should just give him the
touchdown even though he didn't make the
touchdown like that doesn't make much
sense yeah and it especially doesn't
make sense even if you're like well you
know my team kind of won so i just want
to let it slide yeah the problem with
that attitude which is understandable
you know i'm a raging freaking denver
broncos fan and they look like a touch
they think it was a touchdown we just
need to let it slide this time here's
the problem you've just now set in place
a precedent where we're not going to
review things
that's what we're okay so now we're just
going with whatever that ref saw that
was at a weird angle and he called it a
touchdown so we're good and we're just
going to go with that from now on that's
not the president you want to set set
you want to set a precedent of like okay
we have a way
of assessing whether this was actually a
touchdown or not
and that's what we're going to utilize
so you might say you know what i really
want the broncos to win and it kind of
looked like a touchdown but the right
thing to do for future reference and for
future precedence is to say let's go to
the videotape and confirm but the
politicians that said that
and a lot of it was tied to the fact
that the january 6th
event
happened
and that made people just go shh i don't
want to i don't want to catch any flack
for what's going on
this is getting crazy uh let's just move
forward and and call it what it is looks
like they won don't go to the videotape
when the videotape will make people say
yeah you know what
the team won
or
or they say oh the team didn't win and
now we've got some serious issues that
we need to
attend to
it's very strange times man it's a very
strange time what's weird here's what's
weird about this is
me saying what i just said it seems like
pretty normal it seems pretty logical
like well
shouldn't you go to the videotape
no one's gonna listen and say no
they're going to say yeah if you if
that's the rule
and you have the data then why wouldn't
you check it
but you
you transfer that exact analogy analogy
to the
2020 election
and all of a sudden whoever says hey
maybe we should review the information
and the data
is
a savage
you know uh insurrectionist whatever
well it's like
no i'm not an insurrectionist at all
what i want to do is review the data so
if someone says that
they get even worse
accusations yeah so it's very strange
times so do you and you mentioned
something just a second ago about how in
the nfl you only get a few chances to
challenge the call i think i'm not from
nfl yeah and it's been a while really
since i've
you know so that rule could be changed i
don't know but
nonetheless that was a rule at some
point yeah and that's for a reason
because if there's no limit to them let
me challenge every single call and jam
up this whole system this whole game
this whole game is 12 hours long now
because i'm challenging every call that
goes against me right
so
isn't that part of the game too where
but what's interesting about like the
election was people like we don't want
to investigate everything we just want
to make sure that these
key areas that had voting anomalies that
are documented maybe we should check
those out shut up hey no right so
it's almost like a tactic where you
could if you're on the other side right
you could be like hey you're just trying
to stop you're just what do you call you
can't let it go what were they saying
they're saying like um
you can't just accept the truth it's
like that you know you want to paint
them as a as an unlimited uh you know
challenging the call guy you know well
what makes this really scary what makes
it all that really scary
is because i haven't dove enough into
the details
but what makes it really scary is that
what just what joe rogan just talked
about which is hey
people were getting banned from social
media for saying masks didn't work
and now it's the reality people are
getting banned from social media for
saying the vaccine you could still
spread covet even if you had a vaccine
and that is actually true and by the way
people were getting banned for saying
you could still catch covet guess what
that's true so all these things
we didn't have an open conversation
about them because one side got
completely shut down yeah which is crazy
so there you go can't have an open
conversation that's disturbing when you
can't have an open conversation
and and
when what you have to watch out for is
people that
whatever methodology they want to use
raise their voice
and yell over you so whether that means
i'm not so could that be
if you and i are in a discussion
and you start going i don't care about
that and you start you raising your
voice and yelling and talking over me
okay
but that's just you and me i realize
you're just mad whatever but i didn't
get my point across but you don't care
because you leave
that
behavior
in
social media that behavior in the news
that behavior in mainstream media where
oh echo's saying something i don't like
so i'm gonna attack him
raise my voice but through whatever
means that might mean you know
retweeting you with hate calling you
this or calling you that or
doing a personal attack all that
behavior now we're not discussing the
topic yeah we're discussing that i hate
you
which is bad
you ever watched the movie uh the time
machine you ever heard of it and you
didn't watch it but
okay so the time machine is um okay guy
pierce
who is also the star of memento by the
way anyway guy pierce boom he makes time
machine he goes away in the future and
you know he finds that humans have split
um evolutionarily speaking so they were
actually split in three but
so one so he goes with the villagers or
whatever and like he says something
wait a second this could have been
stargate nonetheless
they say he says something and
everything a time machine back to you
before this story
everyone like turns their back or starts
walking away or erases what he wrote
inside or something like that and
so
like somebody explains to him hey like
you can't speak of that
you just can't speak of it yeah and i
think later on they find out like you
know what's behind and stuff like that
and that's the thing
what some of these guys gotta listen to
what they say and it isn't ironic that
neil young's song keep on rocking in the
free world
and he's like don't talk anymore
right like that's crazy right
that's crazy yep that is that's why we
have the underground by the way yeah we
have the underground jackal
underground.com why do we have that why
do we charge 8.18 a month
to to have our own little platform
that this is why
because what we're talking about right
now this may get rolled this might get
bounced yeah this may get edited
right and we're not actually making a
statement one way or the other i'm just
explaining things that have happened
yeah
i i i haven't dug through the details
enough
i don't spend my time digging through
the details of current events i don't do
that
that's not
you know why because i'm not that
interested and because other people that
commit their time to it i'm gonna let
them
let these other people go do that i'm
gonna be reading about world war ii
vietnam korea the peloponnesian wars
that's what i'm doing over on my side
i'm going to be training jiu jitsu
hopefully going surfing playing guitar
those are the things that i'm doing i'm
not parsing through
the news stories that came out in the
last 48 hours to try and get you and
catch you on
something but
when you let a little time go by and we
talked about this on one of the
underground points when you you so i let
time go by and the truth starts to rise
to the surface now it took six to eight
months for the truth to rise the surface
on some of these stories but again you
know how much sleep i lost over these
stories
while they were happening not very much
i wasn't freaking i was like these masks
don't work or i wasn't like you better
put on a mask i didn't lose sleep over
that because i was like hey it doesn't
seem like gonna work that good to me
oh you you know i'm going to carry on
with my life that's what i'm doing
so
we don't know when we might get
suppressed
so that's why we made
jockowunderground.com
if you want to you can help us out if
anything happens to any of these
platforms that you listen to this on we
will still have that platform we do an
extra podcast on it uh about once a week
and we talk about other things that
maybe don't fit quite on draco podcast
but we want to get them out there to
y'all so you can check that out if you
can't afford it look if you can't afford
it's okay
we still got you you can email
what is it assistance
jockonunderground.com we appreciate your
support on that uh you know also we were
talking about american-made companies
you know that's kind of my that's that's
what that's the way i am trying to help
america right now
by building these companies with the
origin team originusa.com if you need to
get boots if you need to get jeans if
you need to get a d which you probably
do
then get go to originusa.com and by the
way you probably you may have seen we
have a hunting line coming out
so we we're going to be making clothes
for hunting that's what we're doing
we've got all kinds of good clothes
coming out as well workout clothes by
the way echo charles so we're going to
cover you down on that as well uh
originusa.com
we also have jacofuel.com i'm
barely
on my game today why i didn't sleep last
night probably got two hours maybe two
and a half
and
i've this is my second jaco discipline
go
which is it which is
a drink it's a drink could you call it
an energy drink you could because it
does have energy in it but
when you hear energy drink you're
thinking oh oh you're going to ingest
some poison that's going to get you uh
jittery and hyper for about an hour and
a half and then you're going to crash
and be sick and be diabetic we're not in
that category no sugar in here sweetened
with monk fruit 95 milligrams of
caffeine get you on that nice little
you're good to go good to go you're good
to go people people go if you don't
sleep
you don't it's like no less than eight
hours of sleep is like being a .08 dui
you're you're mentally impaired
look i'm not saying it's good for you
but it's not as bad as you know look
should you get sleep don't get me wrong
get sleep
sleep as much as you can
sleep as much as you want well
okay don't get crazy but but what i'm
saying is you're
if you sleep a little bit less
and you need a little something hitter
get yourself some jack-o-fuel
jockofield.com yeah and i don't know i
will also contend that even if you got a
lot of sleep
drink because it is good for you yeah
it's healthy for you beautiful look hey
look some people hey some people drink
coffee right in the morning good drink
coffee black coffee whatever you however
you drink coffee
if you get eight hours of sleep what
should you not drink coffee not
necessarily because coffee is kind of
good for you drink some coffee man you
like that one you want that uh as you
would say hit or whatever
the reason same deal
and it's healthy for you so boom you'll
be better off either way also nootropics
in there yep let's not ignore that
that's good for your brain that is
nutrients yep for your brain that's
probably why you don't need to overload
the caffeine with the go yeah you don't
need to because it's got the nootropics
in there get you up there on step
rocking it rolling bro there was a
commercial and i'd i remember the drink
i forget what it was called because i
used to get it's juice straight up juice
like juice juice oh like apple juice
yeah like but it was like a mix i think
i forget what it was but nonetheless
their thing was like feed your brain
well
now as an adult i'm looking i'm like
wait feed your bread isn't there like 50
grams of sugar in that thing right there
savages yeah yep that's jackalfuel.com
don't forget about jocko's store
we're making cool t-shirts it's true
it's true yeah you want to represent
because hey this path is not always easy
yep yep
good to go but it is worth it it is 100
worse and if you want to represent boom
yep you get your shirts your hats the
the subscription shirts continue to
dazzle the
all the senses
oh yeah you got some good ones the shirt
blocker yep the shirt locker you get a
cool new one every month um i we gotta
we got some cool ones
coming out look at that they're always
cool
anticipation is just overflowing over
there
subscribe subscribe to this podcast
youtube the youtube channel
psychological warfare flip side canvas
dakota meyer
you got to get cool stuff to hang on
your wall occasionally yes unless unless
you want a bare wall
which is only applicable in a podcast in
the jocko podcast studio but even though
it's like conspicuously
bare yeah
my house my home
would be bare
were it not for
my wife
because she's hung some stuff on the
walls but that's not appropriate you
should hang stuff on your walls sure
flipsidecanvas.com dakota meyer making
awesome stuff i've written a bunch of
books we got ashland front yeah if you
want if you like what we're talking
about here get some of the books
echelonfront.com leadership consultancy
extremeownership.com is our online
training academy for leadership you can
check that out
also if you want to help service members
retired
service members active duty service
members gold star families the families
of service members check out mark lee's
mom she's got an awesome organization go
to america's
mightywarriors.org if you want to donate
or get involved you can also check out
heroesandhorses.com we got micah fink up
there in the
in the woods in the mountains of montana
helping out vets and if you want more of
us you can find us on social and that's
cool we'll we'll be there but we don't
want you in the algorithm keep out of
the algorithm
echoes adequate charles i am at
jacqueline and
thanks once again
to eli crane for coming on
appreciate your service
in the past
and in the present
eli for arizona.com let's go help eli
win
and to the soldiers sailors airmen and
marines out there
protecting our flag
around the world
thank you
same goes to our police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics
emt's dispatchers correctional officers
border patrol secret service all first
responders
thank you for protecting us here at home
and to everyone else out there
remember that
you do get to write the script of your
life but you have to write around the
things that don't go the way you want
them to
but don't let that stop you
instead
take ownership
and counter-attack those things
that aren't going the way you want them
to
by going out every day
and getting after it
and until next time
zekko and jocko
out